the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
chess Idols are whipping up bizarre
fights with amazing results at the U.S
women's and U.S open championships in St
Louis checkmates it had to be checkmates
to get ahead in this illustrious event
using an opening that belongs in a
museum a Wonder Liang sprung a booby
trap on leader Fabiano caruana but he
avoided the pitfall with scholarly
Precision Jennifer you kept the ball
rolling winning her game and snaking
clear lead in the women's section
results have been all over the map what
new lines will be explored day 10 of
adventurous chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day 10 of the
2022 us chess championships and U.S
women's chess Championships held here in
St Louis we are entering the final
stages of the Championships and the
players are surely going to try to show
their best moves over the chessboard
let's go to the studio and start today's
action with Yasser and Anastasia
from the home of Chess in the United
States welcome to the Saint Louis chess
club and the 10th round of the USGS
championships and the U.S women's
championships
hello everyone I'm Anastasia carlowicz
and I'm here joined by Grandmaster and
fourth time U.S Champion Yasser ceremon
what a pleasure to be here with you
yesterday yeah likewise Anastasia wow it
wasn't yesterday amazing day that was
just a great day we had actually oh it's
a Heart Stopper with Lanier but it was
inspiring by Alice exactly and actually
I was also I noticed that nobody is
satisfied with his position everybody is
still trying to win their games and
linear try to do all his best yesterday
same as Fabi and Alice of course was so
impressive against the arena and Ray
Robson too it was an inspiring day
indeed an inspiration came in all sizes
including the 13 year old Alice Lee as
he stubbornly kept playing for victory I
had dinner last night with Arena crash
and Arena crash was just amazed that her
13 year old opponent puts so much
pressure on her in the game but
Anastasia after such an inspiring round
tell us about the leadership let's start
with the ladies who's in first
and we have Jennifer you who managed to
win her game yesterday and she took it
all for the moment she is leading with
six and a half points out of nine and
then we have Irina Crush who shares the
third position with Megan Lee with six
points Ellis Lee the one you mentioned
they are inspiration on the first place
yes exactly and same then we have a
group of girls with five points
and in the open section who is in first
in that event and we have Fabiano
caruano he's still
um is a Soul Leader yes six and a half
points really impressive at the moment
and Ray Robson follows his steps a half
a point behind only and then we have
linear Dominguez Jeffrey jokes Sam
shankler dagger sweet Savion and a
Wonderland all of them with Five Points
a gap of one point between second and
third and our format for our two
national championships we have round
robin events boss of the Championships
and 14 players are participating 90
minutes for the first 40 moves followed
by 30 minutes for the rest of the game
everybody will have 30 seconds
incremented from move one and no door
offers and our remaining schedule
and the remaining schedule tomorrow is
the rest day
everybody's excited by that one exactly
and after the rest they will have three
rounds to go and the playoffs if needed
on October 20th and drill down and tell
us some more details about the closing
ceremony the closing ceremony will take
less on 20th of October and everyone who
wants to come over get paid well for the
tickets 25 and you are here you can see
your favorite chess players as well as
the commentators we can have a cop we
will have a cocktail party and then
closing ceremony itself and after party
with Digi oh sounds wonderful and it's
streamed as well yes exactly anybody who
cannot do it who cannot make it you can
watch stream online wonderful wonderful
and we're very fortunate to have
Christian in studio uh oh everybody's
getting ready for this round 10 as we
see Megan Lee their uh wait well no her
opponent's there Christian tell us about
this tumultuous U.S women's championship
and the leadership keeps changing first
of all good to see you guys it's great
to be back in the studio uh this is it
we're entering the final stages of of
the event and heavy is the head that
wears the crown especially that is true
in the lady section yesterday we
highlighted the open section but today I
want to see how the leadership has
changed in the ladies section and we're
going to start after round one we see
four players that scored an important
victory in round one specifically I'm
looking at these three players Jennifer
you Megan Lee and Irina Crush Irina
after a round one well she started with
a draw and actually she started with
four draws in the four the first four
games in this tournament let's take a
look how how the leadership changed
after three rounds well we see Megan Lee
blazing hot start for this young lady
two and a half out of three and an
important save against Irina crush and
Jennifer you well she won the first game
and after that scored two draws so two
out of three after three rounds and
let's take a look look at what happened
after six rounds finally we see the only
Grandmaster in the event the a-time
national champion Irina crush with four
and a half points out of six in the
co-leadership position with Jennifer Yu
and Megan Lee is keeping close behind
four points out of six only half a point
behind the leaders and where do we stand
right now after yesterday's ninth round
well we see Jennifer you six and a half
points she leapfrogged both Irina crush
and Megan Lee when right now she's
enjoying the leadership position but we
see how fast that leadership position
changes in this event today is going to
be a very very crucial round for the
standings because we have so many
amazing battles and there you have it
Megan Lee she's ready for today's game
yeah she's definitely gone on her game
face and I saw that Alice Lee was also
in that pack of wolves there in the
ladies but tell us about the pairings
for today's round 10 and what our
viewers can expect starting with the
ladies and we have the leader Jennifer
you playing against
it's a battle between two former U.S
women's Champions Irena crash today will
face Rochelle Wu and then we also have
Ellie sleep playing against andaz a
tonske Megan Lee will play against
Thalia Cervantes that's really a marquee
matchup because if Talia can win just
look at uh she's on the outside looking
in and in the open section what are the
crucial matches pairings in that event
so the leader of Fabiano carono will
play against Christopher you the
youngest participant in this tournament
linear Dominguez will face a Wonderland
and then we have Ray Robson playing
against sam7 and of course the Battle of
two
Titans right yes absolutely Lavon Wesley
and not fighting for first that's quite
the surprise and they've been fighting
hard
and in the ladies what is the price fund
for our participant yeah the total price
month is 160 500 and then the first
place will get 40 000 seconds 30 third
one we'll get to twenty thousand all the
way down to Fourteenth and three
thousand very handsome prices indeed and
in the open section and in the open
section
160
thousand dollar surprise fund the
chamber will have sixty thousand and
then 45 35 all the way to
5500 14. thank you St Louis chess club
for these wonderful national
championships as we see the players
getting wanted uh coming uh for this
round Ted we just saw Jennifer you right
Chris and uh I guess they have to go
through several uh various ages yeah one
digs and you were saying that
Christopher he likes these Polo Yes
actually he changes
he changes only the color exactly yes I
thought what a great idea you don't need
to think what you know where only you
can change the color yes which color it
actually helps you a lot to save some
time tournament leader Jennifer you
there as they get ready once again for
round ten this is a marathon event
because we're catching up after the
pandemic with the various U.S open
Champions as well as Junior
Championships so it's a kind of a
catch-up event instead of the usual 12
player fields we have 14 players making
it a real Marathon Christian absolutely
I only see Sam sevion he has a big game
today against Ray Robson that one is
going to be crucial there's Irina Arena
hat got her cookies I don't want to know
what's in those cookies she needs some
snacks
yes it's a gorgeous day outside the
temperature is a little bit low but my
goodness for a fall day it's so much
Sunshine here in St Louis it's a really
great weather yes I like it so much
October
my favorite Marina looks so different
from Jennifer you okay with this like
Silk shirt
and we hear the Bell as Anna just
getting wanted as well
first as well it seems like Chris bird
told her and oh this is a big Clash guys
I know that these Giants aren't playing
for first that's the shock of this Clash
if you had told me at the start of the
tournament you know what will be the
Marquee matchup in round 10 and would it
determine first place I'd be pointing
towards this game yes it's really
stunning that Lavon has not had a
victory uh two losses and then our
defending Champion Wesley so with the
black pieces uh Nowhere In Contention
either and uh both these gentlemen are
sitting there thinking what has gone
wrong probably not even paying attention
to what opening uh they're going to play
um oh it's really surprising situation
right for Lebon and the Wesley maybe
they were really tired after this
marathon with a single cab and then St
Louis rabbit and Blades followed by nine
six nine elex taking his he took his
first thing before he played this move
uh E5 we were trying to figure out
whether he wants a very uh aggressive
middle game maybe a more aggressive
middle game with D5 or something more
tame more symmetrical after we move one
C5 he decides to create some imbalances
in the position very early on so I like
the trend that this game is showing up
to this point yeah Knight C3 Knight F3
by the way Horror Night separation of
the English and G3 is the most played
yes although I was just about to say no
no kidding Honest Engine at the time he
reached for the epon that Magnus Carlson
has basically blazed a trail almost
single-handedly with this move E2 E4
um I love the cat and mouse of opening
uh play and I referred to the game
between Christopher you and Fabiano now
you're white and you're up against
Fabiano and you know he plays so many
openings and so many things if you play
E4 what what could you expect if you
play D4 what you could expect and so on
so he starts with the move Knight F3
and he says okay are you going to play
into your slav are you going to play
into a grunfeld what exactly are you
going to play into uh I'm going to play
into a early C5 and I may uh not play a
slob but I also invite you to play an
open Sicilian and Christopher like wait
a minute you are going to play a
sicilian against me hmm should I accept
that challenge no no no let's play
symmetrical English and then we have a
four nights English the difference
between our two games one the pawn is on
E5 and the other the pawn is on C5 I'm
actually very curious to see whether
Christopher is going to follow this up
with an early D4 or a Lao black to
potentially go E5 so there is a few ways
in which you can play this position with
white you can go G3 you can go D4
directly oh oh my goodness
well you you you your question has been
answered but did you see how aggressive
he played that movie Joe I didn't it was
oh my goodness he almost wanted to put
it to G4
it's gonna be a different line I'm
telling you guys there was one round
where G4 was played I mean like I'm not
getting like an eight games check this
out D5 CD we there was a recent game in
the ladies Championship
that uh played into the Slime I think it
was like with A3 wasn't an arena
involved yes I think so yes I think it
was Irena versus uh Sophie Mori Suzuki
from a couple of rounds ago yes exactly
as uh I I've this is this was actually a
very very popular line
back in my day as well as a lot of
players with the black pieces were
attracted to this idea of trying to get
a bind in the position of playing for
the move uh E7 E5 I had wow did I have a
a large large number of games uh played
in this line let's just go to some of
our chasing players Jeffrey Zhang
playing the very restrained E2 E3 in his
game with Sam Shanklin a Wonder Liang
Lanier both of these players need a
result if they're hope to catch Ray
Robson
a Wonder Liang yeah this line with
Bishop to D3
um there was a international Master
Danny kopeck and Danny actually played
this bishop D3 variation very very often
in his practice and really I began to
refer to it as the kopeck system because
he yeah he really blazed a lot of trails
on the white side a2a4 lots of familiar
patterns with a rui Lopez but the
difference is that black hasn't put the
Knight on C6 and brought the Knight back
to B8 and then brought it to D7 but
rather played it right away so it's like
a brayer system but you have a better
night yeah but a more kind of
accelerated and finally let's take a
look at a huge game between Sam sevillon
and Ray Robson Sam sevion saved two
lives yes
yeah yeah he's been shaking I mean
against uh yesterday against linear and
before
game that was extremely close to being
absolutely lost well for whom that's a
question that is a good question that is
indeed a good question because then here
played a couple of moves with one second
on uh his clock and we were having a lot
of fun debating that over dinner and
whether it's actually legal to just like
potentially kick your opponent
underneath
very loudly or try to distract your
opponent just for Tuesday for that final
second right right yes and apparently I
think it was Tony Rich uh that you would
mentioned he said he would probably uh
give a lost game a penalty of a lost
game to the person that kicks under the
table or creates the distraction no but
if you if you really want need to sneeze
I mean what can you do right right
that's what we call an act of God
just crazy in the insurance business
there you have it but uh once again look
how crucial a game this is for both
players Ray Robson comes into today's
round in clear second place yes by an
entire Point half a point behind our
tournament leader Fabi but the guy he's
playing against Sam sevillan is one of
those players who's chasing him by a
full point exactly Sam's thinking oh my
god with white yes I would be in second
place uh tied with Rey and vice versa
Ray is thinking okay if I could win and
somebody please stop Fabby you know like
this could have and so but how do you
approach this game exactly Ray Robson do
you try to take any unnecessary risks in
the opening do you try to go all out
you've seen Sam Savion being a bit shaky
exactly losing some steam maybe the
energy levels are not there yet you feel
yourself to be in shape he actually Ray
Robson put a lot of pressure yesterday
with the white pieces against Alex
landerman as well so you're still
definitely in great shape are you going
to try to take more risks and put more
pressure on your opponent play something
like the groovefeld or we kind of have
an answer to that yeah exactly he played
the ragos and excuse me how do you call
this line I'm trying to remember it's
not a drugozian the um
it's not the Vienna it's the um
yes yes
um for whatever reason I was thinking
about it goes in and I was thinking
about the bishop G5 lines in the
Sicilian but this is of course the
rogozin and we've seen it played at the
top level so many times with the black
pieces right exactly but it's not
necessarily a very tame but white has a
lot of ways in uh which they can quiet
down the game and just play for a slight
Advantage Queen A4 check is one of them
not so much in like the groomfeld or
things of that nature the king's Indian
defense something a bit more aggressive
do you do you go for that and risk
losing but also give yourself a higher
chance of catching up with the leader
well not really try to do something
wrong let's say immediately I think
you'll just try to play this game slowly
and check what his opponent would like
to do I don't think he will take some
unnecessary risks at this moment and is
yeah I mean we know that Ray wants to
win this event right he has a dream the
dream he told us the players the only
thing he needs to achieve right now is
to win the U.S championship and then you
have met his goals of being an Olympic
medalist then uh 2700 player yes and the
U.S Champion but you cannot take it all
maybe in one event so step by step well
maybe you can
you should try to maximize I think so
you have to use the serum field Theory
which are yeah the serum field Theory
prescribes yes that when you have a
choice
between two desirable objects you should
expand your capacity to accept both and
in this case he wanted to be an elite
player and a U.S Champion so become the
U.S champion and become an elite player
I love it yes sir it didn't go so far
away it's just a place in my case if I
want if I like both shoes both pairs I
normally can buy both of them
that means that you accept it
exactly I was thinking about the Richter
Rouser everything
right everything starts with an RS yeah
from the Sicilian now is that well
everything you guys were talking about
who's going to take risks what kind of a
game do I want if I'm in Sam shoes what
kind of a game do I want if I'm in Ray
shoes right now is one of those moments
where a lot of those questions can be
asked and answered if you want to play
very solid with white you play E2 E3 at
this point so that Pawn on C4s and
hanging later you play for Queen C2 and
then you try to make the case that with
the Knight on C6 it's not so easy for
black to counter in the center if you're
really in a frisky mood you want to play
all out for a win you can go into some
very very sharp lines which begin with
the move Bishop G5 and then you've got
d-take C4 and I mean to say away you go
I mean these are very very complex
variations so it depends on the white
right now right where do you go and Sam
asked and answered with the move E2 E3
let's play solid and let's see where we
go Christian uh back over to you and
tell tell us what caught your eye well
I'm still trying to catch up with what's
happening in the Christopher you versus
Fabiano game and let's take a look at
what happened we were discussing this G3
D5 now you can take take Bishop to G2
and that's the position the type of
position we've seen in the game between
Irena rush and Sophie Mori Suzuki but
Christopher you decided to go for a
completely different line one that
starts with the move a D4 and now we
have the C takes D4 Knight takes D4
detail C4 Knight takes C6 and now we're
going to be storming into uh this end
game this is the position we currently
have on the board upon up for black most
likely this Pawn is going to be lost now
the question is how is it going to be
lost if I manage to Corral it with the
Rook let's say bring the bishop out get
the Knight to E3 get the Rook to C1 and
then capture on C4 and maintain the pawn
structure as it is A7 and C6 versus A2
and a B2 that's going to be very
favorable for white so generally
whenever you attack it with the move
Knight to E3 black just tries to give up
the pawn go C3 and then we're going to
have a symmetrical structure I still
like wise chances but of course this
type of end game surely has been
analyzed by Fabiano caruana at home and
he knows potentially hopefully he knows
hopefully for him he knows how to deal
with White's pressure white still a
little bit ahead nevertheless it feels
like this is quite a tame approach to
try to beat Fabiano caruana all right
I'll turn our attention to the ladies
championship for a moment I'm looking at
the game between Arena crush and
Rochelle Wu and it will not have escaped
Arena's attention that Jennifer
won against Rochelle in a position as
white where Jennifer got in this you
know Queen side expansion with the pawn
on C5 that particular game featured the
bishop on F4 in this particular case
Arenas left her Bishop on B2 eyeballing
the E5 Square making it as difficult as
possible for black to get in the freeing
break E6 E5 uh Arena will have seen that
Rochelle really did not I want to say
feel the position very well a lot of
Rochelle's moves in that game against
Jennifer really did not fit and Jennifer
won a very uh nice smooth Victory so
arena is looking to do the same recipe
if you will as did Jennifer let's jump
to our tournament leader as we mentioned
coming in air Jennifer is up against a
former Champion Naji and she's played
this again this English but it's not a
nimso Indian because I haven't yet
exactly I haven't yet committed upon the
D4 uh Jennifer played Queen B3 basically
saying yes I really do want you to trade
on C3 but I'll recapture with McQueen I
won't uh double my pawns A5 on the
pardon me C5 defensive Bishop expecting
A2 A3 and again trying to coax black
into capturing the Knight if I play A3
and you drop back with the bishop then
G2 G3 Bishop G2 and again a lot of
similarities with the nimzo Indian but
not not exactly a proper names of Indian
at all let's jump to Anna zatonski and
Alice Lee
again a 13 year old yesterday what she
did was just
amazingly playing for a whiz and then
going into an end game of four pawns he
had the pawns versus Ohio whole Rook
executive still is playing for the win
even there refused A number of
repetitions impressive that Irina said
that she never had this kind of ending
but she knew it's going to be a draw
like her assessment was also very very
good same as your well even though she
never got the end yes it seemed like
she played it with awareness with really
really a lot of understanding Anna
satonski White against Alice Lee the
Queen's Gambit accepted I've got to say
uh again if it waxes and wanes and
fashion sometimes everybody plays it and
it's just like it's like the the the
answer to 1d4 you know just go Queen's
Gambit accept it go into these endings
play like Wesley so and draw them and
then other times everybody says no no no
groom Fels are the great excitement a7a6
uh well there are just so many
approaches Bishop Bishop to D3 Bishop to
B3 Queen E2 this position has been
played literally thousands of times and
we'll just keep an eye on this one
Christian uh back over to you and uh
what what happened in that ending that
you were telling us about so they are
playing quite quickly let's take a look
at what happened and once again we're
talking about the Christopher versus
Fabiano game Knight to D5 was played
Knight to E3 E6 you have to defend the
Knight on D5 and the pawn on C3 what you
don't want to do is take on E3 because
after Bishop takes C6 or even Bishop to
E3 and then threatening uh to take on C6
this position is quite bad you're going
to go Bishop to D7 I'm going to go Rook
to C1 pick up uh the pawn on C4 you're
going to lose the pawn on C6 you also
have huge problems with the pawn on A7
and I don't have any weaknesses in my
position you cannot play chess like this
with the black pieces so
after Knight to E3 E6 was played Knight
takes C4 of course pick up the pawn why
not Bishop to A6 immediately and this is
key to Black strategy you have to
immediately put pressure on your
opponent you cannot let white stabilize
the position finish the development with
short Castle because after that you will
be in strategical danger to be much
worse and now white has a couple of
options Knight to A5 or the move B3
which I believe was just played on the
board B3 is uh played on the board now
Bishop to B4 seems to be the main line
once again keep the pressure on your
opponent do not allow white to Castle
Bishop to B4 Bishop to date one I think
it's important to set up the tension
between the Bishops for example after
King E7 if you do try to Castle I'm
going to take on D2 and then the pawn on
E2 is hanging you will be actually worse
as white so you cannot castle at least
not in a favorable situation if you try
to take first on B4 and then Castle now
I can just simply take on C4 the
structure is quite symmetrical and I'm
the one taking advantage of the open
files B and the D file so root to d8 in
fact I do believe that right now black
is probably just simply a better I'm
going to be able to play the move C5
after I put the Rook on B8 absolutely no
problems for uh for black so
this position is quite intriguing how is
white going to uh create any separation
in the position probably Rook to C1
makes a lot of sense cement the Knight
on C4 now whenever you take on C4 I take
back with the Rook this is the type of
position you don't want to play as black
because now I go Rook to C1 I put a lot
of pressure on your opponent C6 you will
lose that at some point and the Knight
despite the fact that it looks it has a
very stable Outpost it's not as stable
at some point I'm going to be able to
play the move E4 kick the Knight back
take more space in the center and make
use of the fact that I have a very nice
connection between my Rooks and my
Bishop on G2 so this one is not looking
good for black black has to play
something a bit more after Bishop to B4
Bishop D2 King E7 let's say root to C1
Rook H to C8 once again you cannot
Castle you have to find a way to Castle
to get your other Rook if you manage to
fly The Rook on D1 that would be great
right but unfortunately that's not
possible you cannot play Fly chess like
this so Rook HCA this is what I'm
expecting let's see do we have any more
game any more moves no B3 was the last
move this is the position and right now
Fabiano is trying to probably remember
the setup needed for the position and uh
for his case to equalize the game in
this one exactly but still Fabi uh
thinking I've got this really youthful
opponent sitting across from the board
from me how can I use my experience
exactly yes this is right and let's not
forget Christopher lost a seemingly
equal end game against Jeffrey Sean a
couple of days ago with the white pieces
as well that's right when he played the
C4 movies yeah unexpectedly absolutely
um Anastasia you were talking about the
psychology of the players when they come
into this very crucial round 10 and you
know how much risk do they want to take
with the white pieces and how much risk
do you want to take with the black piece
turning our attention a game between
Megan Lee and Talia Cervantes again
Talia coming into this game is one point
behind Megan and she won two games in a
row absolutely nice games
and she's thinking let me press my luck
with the black pieces so
uh an invitation by Talia let's dance at
the night or party go ahead and play
Bishop
let's go let's go this is really sharp
stuff the next party at the St Louis
chess club should be called the neither
right right I mean get your tickets you
know there are different cocktails right
even here you can find karwana cocktail
right there exactly across the streets
these chests
named cocktails but I've never heard of
neither party now
yes you haven't lived you've got to get
out more
uh Bishop E3 and with this move uh Megan
said okay I'm gonna play a king uh
pardon me I'm gonna play an English
attack with F3 and G4 and uh let's see
what you're going to do okay Knight to
G4 I said I'm going to attack the bishop
now there's a whole I mean literally
books can be written about the outcome
of Bishop G5 H6 Bishop H4 G5 Bishop G3
Bishop G7 one Gary Kasparov would be a
very very good author of such a book
because he played on the black side many
times now the crazy part is in Grand
Master practice the move Bishop C1 has
really provoked the move Knight F6 and I
remember a very famous game I think it
was Luke McShane versus Hikaru Nakamura
in a millionaire tournament where they
couldn't offer each other draw they had
a repetition like this
but again this whole idea of who's going
to risk who's going to play for the win
it's also psychological right I mean yes
sir like for example Megan explained
with white pieces now and after her loss
yesterday maybe she's not in the best
mood right now but at the same time you
play with white pieces and you cannot
really afford normally to give away your
white color so like that right exactly
fight it with yourself at this moment
like would you like to make a draw with
white pieces in 10 moves and have some
rest let's say before the last round or
you still kind of have to push yourself
and play this game and sometimes you're
really not in the mood to play right
exactly well that is exactly the
question that Megan is asking tell you
should we would you like to con to
repeat right just at least just once yes
and tell you said
no no no no no no no no no no no I will
not play Knight F6 and I will not uh
even entertain the rapid such a
repetition I'm gonna play night
um C6 uh and and how would you uh like
to play the position yes well h2h3 on
the board Knight came back to F6 and now
we have just a kind of I want to say
open Sicilian but a couple of
differences well in the first place
h2h3 like we could have gotten this
position from the starting position
right here Knight F6 H3
Knight C6 and you kind of say well H3 is
a soft move that's not good so black
game something with that white says well
it may be a soft move but maybe not
Knight C6 isn't the most critical answer
to H3 maybe now I can play for a cares
attack with G4 and maybe your knight you
would prefer to have your Pawn on E6
maybe your knight on D7 so again this
game of cat and mouse and who has
outfoxed who and got the position that
they want out of these openings actually
if you look at this game also from
Thalia perspective like she won two
games in a row she has five points out
of nine heropant has six so in case if
Thalia wins this game she actually will
share probably second place third place
who knows right and it's really
important before the rest day and before
the last rounds to try to catch with the
with leaders at this moment so maybe she
is in a very very like optimistic
aggressive aggressive mood and maybe she
would like to try she is actually this
type of player who is not afraid of
anyone thinks you for for sure I would
really like to buttress exactly what you
said and I I really think that Talia was
experiencing uh great pangs of
frustration in the first five rounds it
has so many draws and that's not her
nature she's really uh aggressive swings
for the fences and expects uh a lot of
losses but a lot of wins as well and
those draws were really
injuring her spirit but okay she's got a
fight on her hands let's see uh how it
goes and Christian over to you what's
happening in the Sam Savion game let's
see what's happening in this one because
this is once again crucial to the
standings so Queen to A4 Castle was
played and this move Bishop to uh D2
take on C4 take on C4 and now Bishop to
D6 now Black's plan is very clear at
some point after I removed Bishop D7
perhaps or even before in the move
Bishop to D7 you want to play the move
E5 E5 is most likely going to uh Force
White's hand to change the structure in
the position if you do take so for
example castle and then E5 if you take
on E5 this is considered to be harmless
for uh black this type of positions
we're going to exchange a lot of pieces
I'm going to get the queen to E7 Pawn on
C6 the majority on the queen side versus
the majority in the center and on the
king side it seems to be quite equal
there is absolutely no chances for why
to get an early opening Advantage so
white has to try to find something else
in the position after E5 most likely you
want to push D5 but then again I will
Retreat the Knight then attack and hook
that pawn on D5 with the move C6 and
once again this is considered to be
harmless let's see what Sam Savion came
up with because he's still blitzing out
his moves he played this move Knight to
B5 Knight to B5 Bishop to D7 makes a lot
of sense you're going to take on D6
you're going to take on D6 and now this
move Queen to A3 immediately pressuring
the pawn on these things also getting
out of Dodge of these potential ideas of
Knight takes D4 so if you go Castle
Knight takes D4 well you don't want to
fall for this type of ideas right
Discovery attacks so Queen 283 makes a
lot of sense it's the best placement for
the queen attacking taking uh control
over the dark squares as well because it
makes sense you just took the dark score
Bishop Black's dark Square Bishop off
the board right so it makes sense that
you're going to try to take advantage of
that and control the darks worse now
Knight to E4 is one of the ways black
can play D5 is another one I really like
this move Knight to E4 you took my dark
Square Bishop I'm going to try to take
yours right and establish let's say the
balance in the position like that now
castle if you don't do go Castle I can
take take and play the move uh D5 and we
get at this type of position which
favors Fabiano caruana because Ray
Robson is probably not going to win at
least one and if Bobby doesn't lose his
game either he's still going to maintain
his lead so far be most likely is
looking at the game and he's
understanding that uh most likely Ray
Robinson is not going to win this one
and it does seem like Sam Sabian also is
quite well prepared he played the move
Knight to E4 yeah Ray Robson after a
long thing played the move Knight to E4
it's the most logical move in the
position and we see an immediate
response by Sam Smith and by the way
he's blissing out his moves 1 hour and
30 minutes still for Sam at this point
Bishop to D3 now are you going to take
on D2 and play D5 are you going to go D5
and try to cement the Knight on e4 and
keep the Knight on e4 as it is this is
once again another question for Ray
Robson to answer uh thank you for that
Christian I think that that was a kind
of a unique novelty in my practice as a
commentator that in the game between Sam
Savion and Ray Robson we were told that
Fabi gains an advantage
[Laughter]
that's a good point yes I'm stunned guys
uh look I played uh English all my life
and I'm referring to the game between
Jennifer and Naji and this is I mean the
most standard standard uh position that
you can get in these kinds of englishes
and boy I want to say E3 G3 D4 I mean
even if you really want to have a little
uh hot sauce you know you could you
could go for the G4 move so if you want
to have fun if you want to have fun uh
before like nobody and I mean nobody has
played the move that Jennifer you has
played in this position E4 E4 and it
instantly came no games found whoa I was
like well I certainly don't know this
move e to E4 what about Bishop C3 now a
bishop C3 Queen
c34 is not possible because G7 well at
least I I don't lose upon and I've got
the two Bishops after so E4 and okay
Jennifer is mixing it up early and of
course if I'm in in in White Shoes my
next let's say you make a bad move this
is a terrible move uh please E5 and I
would Chase your knight to the edge of
the board and I would quickly yes
nc5 is also hanging so yeah bingo bingo
right so uh not actually understanding
that E5 and maybe even potentially D4 is
White's follow-up she's played the very
natural Knight C6 and said look if you
play for E5 and I go Knight G in this
case
exactly maybe you can still afford to
play Knight E4 here okay and then
because I'm looking at Knight D6 check I
don't like uh I'm I'm going outside yeah
yeah yeah I've escaped The Far Side
exactly exactly what can I do now if I
was hanging and actually I don't know if
the other one trade c545 I wouldn't
imagine that this could possibly uh be
better for uh White I can only imagine
to be better for black so the move
Knight C6 uh responds to the challenge
of E4 it says exactly what are you doing
D3 that doesn't look very good I mean I
could drop a knight in on D4 you
probably don't even want to take it so
you probably probably end up having to
play Bishop E2 and maybe after Castle's
now I start to think I'm better as black
anyway the movie or sometimes still can
hurt right even if you can you can Lucy
Four Points oh black is definitely black
is good just black is better black is
better right all right yeah it's that
simple in the position that you guys are
mentioning
um which has the option of Knight to D4
but also the option of playing D5 right
it doesn't play them with D3 once you
play them well you have to defend them
yes right you know I can play the move
D5 as well Knight to D4 is an option D5
is an option I'm taking over the
initiative as black it makes perfect
sense I have everything in the position
I haven't even lost my dark Square
Bishop which usually happens and your
whole strategy playing Queen to B3 A3
trying to Target uh that dark Square
Bishop actually it feels like it helps
me because at some point I'm going to
switch diagonals I'm going to go from A5
to C 7 especially after this move a D5
maybe even create that battery with the
move Queen to D6 and Target you on the
king side this one I mean the options
are all in Black's camp at this point
okay maybe uh if I'm if I'm going to how
do you say argue on behalf of Jennifer
uh novel approach E4 maybe I have to
borrow a page from Danny kopeck Play
Bishop to D3 I mean it's a little
awkward my Bishop being in a front of my
Pawn how is this bishop ever going to
develop if the pawns on B2 and D2 remain
on their squares at least in this case
with Bishop D3 castles and rookie one I
can imagine a scheme of development
where I'm not losing or worse or
something but uh Jennifer's move E2 E4
over the board inspiration but it might
lead her into some difficulties but
that's her usual style of play right we
know and she may mentioned it she likes
this provocative I'm not playing uh good
openings in this tournament I don't have
time to uh good opening oh yes right I
have academics I need to submit papers
take my opponents out of the opening and
just play a game at the expense of me
being worse early on in the opening
that's okay yes and then you go to your
University and you say you know guys I
also couldn't study all these things
you know it works both ways oh that's
fantastic you have to play the game
Championship if you didn't know look at
look here Saint Louis chess club YouTube
channel yes I was exhausted these this
round lasted all the time and Jennifer
at Harvard Harvard student can use the
excuse for both sides and I have a
question please hypothetically she wins
the US Women's championships would she
be the first woman that wins both the
Junior and the woman's title in the same
year wow
no and the reason I'm gonna say no is I
have it in mind that Arena was such a
youthful uh player when she was growing
up she was a prodigy and essentially yes
that I I'm gonna guess that she won both
both in the same year yeah yeah
we'll we'll find out speaking of Arena
let's just go to the game between Arena
and Rochelle for just a moment because
things have uh definitely transpired
important uh moment here after the move
Rook E8 well if you've ever want to
Telegraph your idea you've done it with
this move Rook E8 the move rookie eight
seeks to play the move E6 E5 why is that
so important well ask the bishop on C8
how it feels yeah he's not feeling well
not feeling well is it really a threat
like if I play Pokemon like for example
once or with the night yes even to
provoke your night to to take it only
five years yes so now I think again yes
and then maybe I can jump with my knight
somewhere it's so nice or night before
with the idea to go tonight to D6
yes Jennifer play D5 uh oh wow uh that's
Ultra aggressive yes it is that's really
doubling down if you will on her whole
idea but the engines are now saying that
she's lost after 19 after Knight G4 yeah
they are giving black a decisive
Advantage almost decisive Advantage
minus 1.6 I would call it right closer
to uh two pawns Knight to E4 I think
this is what you guys were discussing
yeah well yes right how you will defend
get out of Dodge of this uh exactly B6
you take this I take this but I mean
you've lost so many tempies trying to
spawn this Pawn on C5 the Knight on C5
is in fact going to be a Target later on
in the game I have all the trumps in the
position this one is not looking good
for a Jennifer so wow uh Nazi finds the
move Knight to G4 which makes a lot of
sense I mean why not where else will you
put put your knight you cannot go to D5
you cannot go to E4 you probably have to
go by elimination you're forced to make
the best move in the position
sometimes it's funny right yeah you want
your opponent to make a mistake but
there is no way to make a mistake no
maybe this is the case like Knight G4 is
more or less the only move exactly okay
this might be trouble and we've seen how
difficult it is to hold on to that
leadership position in the ladies
section
it always changes so you know Jennifer
maybe in a bit of a trouble in this game
well sometimes I mean you sit there and
you come in and you have this over the
board inspiration and you win like the
most fantastic game ever and they go wow
what great preparation you go no no no
no it's over the board inspiration and
then you have these other moments of the
over the board inspiration and then you
say well you know nobody's ever played
that before well there's a reason that
nobody ever played it before it could be
that it's just bad
moves the engine is saying after seven
moves whites that is to say Jennifer's
position is just bad bad bad and again
if you don't want to go down material 94
is the only move uh of course we can all
understand that Knight D6 check could be
um disruptive yes
castles and of course we understand that
you you take a pawn but uh I'm
uh bear with me here guys because again
this isn't my doing but uh she must be
thinking that she's got Knight takes B7
as a bailout in her Mind's Eye she might
be calculating that any trades and
she'll get to play B4 and life oh it's
good brings it new but but but but but
actually this bishop was hoping maybe to
be retreated or there is something here
yes well I don't know I mean at the
moment I've got a four exactly so I'm
Queens well I need to move my queen
queen C7 I will
gratefully take and maybe I'll just I'll
just try the bail maybe you'll have this
queen be six or whatever
I'm Dreaming this this dark swear Bishop
so I mean I can only imagine that this
is you know what Jennifer when she went
for E4 was calculating now before you
reach for the E5 Pawn Yeah Knight G4
Knight E4 on the board before you reach
for the E5 Pond uh after castles you
have another move too yes I thought
about this but then before yeah let's
have a look see yes
oops and F2 yeah and you have no
and then Queen H4 maybe something
I I'm doing my best to hang on but I
don't think I'm hanging on I think I'm
just well in fact I think I just uh
coughed up a
pawns so that might be the point right
there that after Knight takes C5 don't
take the E5 Pawn so quickly but rather
Leave the Night yes great idea yes to
keep the net on G4 and try to take
advantage of this diagonal
basically it's a nice idea actually yeah
it might be something that Jennifer
missed although again uh for example
three years trying to protect everything
yes right
trying to protect everything the F2 and
the E5 I think this is not good I I
don't like whites this is for foreign
it doesn't it it doesn't feel like a
very harmonious idea I wanted to say uh
before we got completely sidelined big
things big developments were taking
place between Arena and Rochelle she
played immediately 95 let's go for that
one right to stop Yes number five just
in case and then Irina said okay now I'm
really serious about stopping you from
playing E5 I'm gonna go Knight to E5
myself and if I can play F4 exactly in
this position guess what there is no way
I mean that you're gonna get in uh any
of central breaks so Rochelle felt that
she had to take 97 by the way protecting
against Knight B6 and gift need the
bottom F4 foreign
we've caught up with the players again
this is the game between Arena and
Russia so if Jennifer should loosen oh
my gosh that opens up the uh window for
arena Megan Atlas Lee uh jump we can
have a even I mean maybe tide for the
first place okay it depends yes so arena
for sure has chances so as Christian
used to say uh this game is critical
also for arena right so now Arena has
some Advantage right right
she has an advantage in the position
following the trend but she also has the
advantage because of this game and she
doesn't know it right I like the way you
think I mean this is going to be our new
approach yeah now I'm going to be really
good players we have to be thinking a
few days ahead right in the game of
elshon Ray benefits by this trade of
Brooks
that's a good point actually we're
adding New Dimensions exactly what do
you have for us well actually I'm
looking at this game between ashrita and
begging because Beckham is also
yeah uh one and a half points behind
Jennifer if Jennifer loses begging wins
that's only half you you get the map
right so check this out check what's
happening in this one a very similar
structure actually it started off as a
very similar structure but with reversed
colors nevertheless Beckham seems to be
doing with the black pieces the right
things and that is to develop her pieces
not as Jennifer you is doing right now
going for the pawns and ideas with E4 or
respectively E5 in Jennifer's game G6
get the pieces out Knight to E7 Bishop
to E2 Castle H6
King to H7 so white is hinting that
potentially uh she's going to try to get
and by the way with this move she's
definitely hinting at the plan uh
related to Knight to C2 followed by the
move a B4 she played the move a391 we're
expecting ideas of Knight to C2 and
follow uh that with the move B4 black on
the other hand is hinting at the fact
that most likely there's going to be
some developments happening on the queen
side H6 King to H7 F5 is the natural
follow-up but you look at the position
in general whenever you see this type of
structures and you see the opportunity
uh that is presented right now for black
and that is the move D5 you can take
advantage of the fact that everything
what white is doing right now it doesn't
really tie together very well I can take
advantage and have a beautiful structure
in the center a lot of space advantage
in the center and if you compare it to
any sort of Sicilian what is this Knight
doing on E1 right it's it's not really
doing much you don't want the night in a
sicilian to go on C2 or C7 right so it
seems that if Beckham decides to go with
this move uh D5 or even the Preparatory
Bishop to E6 and follow that up with the
move D5 she will stand better and she
will stand to take the early advantage
in this one and actually I'm not 100
sure if you guys talked about this game
as well the one between Arena and
Rochelle
but I realize doing really well exactly
yes she's doing really well and she has
the space advantage on the king side and
on the queen side as well for black is
very difficult to break right right you
would love to play this move B6 but once
you do that I take take and I have the
C5 score for my knight not only that
lesson a lot of pressure on the C file
right I don't have any weaknesses in the
position F6 doesn't really work in this
type of position that's going to open up
uh the long diagonal and I'm going to be
there to meet that with the Bichon B2
and pressure you on the king side this
one is not looking good for Rochelle and
Irina is definitely filling it at this
moment just a quick question for you
Christian in that position with Arena at
the moment uh I I from taking borrowing
a page from what happened yesterday uh
this idea of H4 and H5 soften up soften
up the the the black king side a bit why
not why not is an option of course yeah
you can go H4 most likely if you go H4 I
will try to take advantage of the fact
that let's say you weaken a little bit
and I have to do something you have to
do something I need to do something I I
thought F6 was actually forced and
that's why I was playing H4 because I
thought okay I take on I know again if
you go uh H5 I think G4 are uh great
ideas in the position I can even go
maybe even Bishop to D4 now the problem
is Bishop H5
absolutely yes but you have time right
because once you play the move H5 F6 is
no longer an option very proud why
because the pawn on G6 is a big weakness
right and once we exchange this I have
ideas of Rook F3 Rook G3 I'm going to
put a lot of pressure on your G6 pawn
and that one is going to fall F6 is no
longer an option so I have time how what
is your other option uh of a break as
black B6 so I'm going to take control
all of that as well with the move Bishop
to D4 I'm going to go Rook F3 maybe I'm
going to go King to H2 and then G4 I
have so many useful plants in my
position space this is just looking like
a play on one goal yeah it looks really
great actually in open section we had
lots of development oh really uh before
we just jump there maybe just one one
more look at the Megan Lee game because
I was just very very curious how the
Talia yes Megan Lee pardon me and Talia
Cervantes game was going to unfurl after
this move H3 Knight F6 guess what G4 yes
E5 and oh that was it I just thought uh
okay we get this Kara's attack where the
move H3 is on the board this move G4 uh
you kind of cements the control over the
the F5 Square I'm thinking Knight F5 but
wait a minute
as black in such positions I mean it
looks a little bit crazy
sometimes uh this bishop can actually
work
okay this is a fun position I'm really
not sure where it's going to go I I
remember it might be three or what oh
she did remember games of
um Alex
Zander Ivanov uh he really liked to play
these positions as white he would bring
his Knight to G2 he put his Bishop
pardon me Knight to E2 put his Bishop on
G2 Castle play Knight to D5 and then
swing the Knight kingside he won a
remarkable number of games like it was
almost like he had a system okay okay
open section yes Pecos Anastasia where
we'd like to go
I wonder Liang yes versus whoa look I
mean how many pieces left the board
already and that was fast I don't know
this ending I wanted to ask you it's
like this kind of painting was two
Bishops against two knights but the
position
nicely uh gives the Knight on D7 a
tremendous Square once on C5 it will hit
the d3b3 A4 E4 Square as well you don't
want to allow such a knight and after
the move d4 you've got no choice you've
got to do ampasan yeah yeah and let's
see what has happened
I'm just so many moves like well all of
them right right that's what it must be
yes I think it's all Theory
I wonder
has one hour 34 minutes meaning that he
started with an hour 30. he gets 30
second bonus for every movie he's made
so he's gotten a four minute or actually
four and a half minutes so it's almost
like he's played every single move
instantly no no it's one hour and 30.
and Thursday okay one hour 30 minutes
and 30 seconds yes one hour 34. yes here
it's 34 yes here Amaya on your yes I I
agree with you yes sir you have search
reports so yeah I can confirm I'm being
cheated
wait a minute okay you were about to ask
I would say that 34 is not such a big
difference I mean it's clear that linear
spend more time thank you yes thank you
um I'm uh I I'm satisfied
um two nights versus two Bishops that's
the imbalance but uh we know that when
ever you have the nights the knights are
looking for Outpost stocks yes you know
if they don't have any outposts you've
got a problem you put the pawn back on
E6 and you start to understand that this
Knight on C3 has a problem in this
particular case the Knight does have two
pretty Splendid outposts D5 and B5 which
I would say
is compensation because I do believe
that the two Bishops are stronger than
the two knights uh in most positions in
this position I put a knight on D5 if I
if you ever have to give up your light
squared Bishop then it's Knight versus
dark swear Bishop maybe black is unhappy
by any trade but this moment everybody's
playing so quickly yes Christian I don't
know but it feels like white is fine no
I mean I have feeling that white has
quite a nice position that this is also
like in BB K5 maybe sometimes okay I can
imagine that you want to maybe yes maybe
double down and go with an idea this is
all known
I don't know how well known it is it was
played twice okay twice it was played
twice and in fact were the names both of
those games uh continue with Queen to B8
right now Queen to ba Queen to B8 which
is a bit of a weird move not even the
computers uh Main Line okay I do believe
this might be some sort of
Correspondence games Queen uh Richter
versus uh schupen from 2019 and post PC
versus Acevedo
so yeah it sounds like correspondence
there but the name and what year then
2018 and 2019. so okay
it's not the return right it's not the
Richter Rouser right that we came to
understand uh Queen B8 okay I can
understand that the queen yeah should
belong on maybe these squares
I can understand that you wanted no
there is you know get off the D file but
why wouldn't you play Queen to B6 unless
you were trying to bring the Bishop from
E7 to C5 wow this is too deep
it makes a lot of sense as well exactly
and to be honest from a practical
perspective from a human's eye it makes
the most sense I would assume the
difference between Queen to B8 and queen
to B6 is that at some point I will do
this maneuver Knight to E1 Knight to C2
Knight to E3 and then Knight to D5 is
going to come with temple maybe that's
one reason why you wouldn't put the
queen on uh d8 also Knight D5 directly
and that's going to come with tempo as
well like also Queen B6 like you protect
Pawn on A5
so that's why
a remarkable uh game going on and let's
just take a look linear fell asleep but
it seems like Fabi fell asleep as well
did he make a move or is he still let's
uh take a look at Bobby's position he is
playing Christopher you and you have
been discussing this ending uh uh quite
some time Christian and some time ago
you focused on the Move Bishop B4 check
as well as maybe just a kind of a
preparatory move Rook C8 and you were
you were trying to mention that the fact
that you don't really want to give white
all the time that white wants to Castle
Play Bishop B2 Rook C1 why because at
the end of the day you'll just have
split pawns as black you'll be trying to
make a draw that's not what uh what's on
fabby's mind uh coming into today's game
is Fabi on a 40-minute thing
[Music]
what is his personal record for longest
think time that's a good question but
foreign
not at all and again if you don't mind a
Christian just kind of tell us what it
is about this position that's caused
Fabby to stop once again it's kind of a
mystery to me because it has been played
a lot of times it has been played 68
times in this database and in fact
there's a lot of known names uh at the
top uh games uh leaderboard we see
aronian versus gelfon we see kramnik
versus uh Peter lecko evanchuk versus
Peter leco Wow
versus we did more recently we're seeing
a lot of big names in this position and
most of them play the move uh Bishop to
B4 so I'm a bit surprised because it's
Fabi in general is very much aware of
what the ins and outs especially of
theory are and he doesn't seem to be
very familiar with the opening in this
particular game and right now
either falling down to his last 49
minutes out of the opening against one
hour and 26 minutes maybe he's asking
for him hurt you and then it's sort of
like well dude why did you think 40
minutes on this well well-known move
Bishop before 35 minutes ago was better
yes exactly exactly so yes but you know
sometimes you're kind of trying to find
the position right that you play with
this young player you think you want to
look for the position you have at least
some chances to press him that's right
and you don't see them and you try to
think which variations I have to enter
in order to get at least something and
probably he kind of couldn't find any
yeah and and where do I lead the game uh
that will make it that much more Awkward
for my opponent to play by the way talk
to Chris bird said you needed to come
over I had some doubts about my
commentator there she she she's finding
all the good moves I I want you to
wander as security protection and
everything he said yes sir that's not my
problem the players are my problem not
the commentary yeah someone needs
another Armature here I tell you you
can't find good Arbiters these days but
not what they used to be yes so you're
off the hook today
we're going to go through security uh on
you but as always we want to reach out
to our audience first of all say uh
thank you very much for uh joining our
show and making it so much a more
enjoyable for us how can you do that
well you can ask the commentators and
how can our audience join it as
Anastasia yeah we're really looking
forward for all your questions and you
can do it by simply subscribing to our
social media channels and and in Twitter
account St Louis chess club then you can
ask your questions and put the hashtag
us chess Champs or mention St Louis
chess club in your Tweet and yes we have
a couple of questions all right let's go
here it comes
um uh Serious Sam wow oh actually the
question is really fits the discussion
like what's your advice for managing
your emotions after losing a winning
game in a tournament with with some
Seven Day games left to play WoW P.S
shout out something yeah okay ah yes I
think you think this I didn't see you
yesterday very very very nice
this is so tough this is so tough how
how to uh
control your emotions I want to say I
mean the worst thing that can ever
happen in a game of chess is losing of
course losing is terrible but I don't
even start to play it I know losing is
her it's very very painful and uh one of
my very favorite quotes I love these
world champions uh and to quote them
Magnus Carlson was doing a press
conference and a little boy in the
audience said when did you learn to stop
crying after a loss Magnus looked at the
little boy and said what makes you think
I've stopped crying and that's that's
tough that's tough what's your advice I
mean yes sir I don't know I mean I also
it depends probably on the way you lose
your game and the sound loses you take
it let's say easier than the others
right I also cannot tell you that I'm
really a good loser I'm not a good it's
actually funny that I thought about it
one day like I'm the person who normally
comes to players after they lose the
game sometimes and they have to ask
these questions and I remember playing
in the tournament and I lost the game
like completely very stupid way and I
thought if now somebody would have even
come to me and asked me even one
question I don't know what I would do
with this person you know so I really
appreciate the fact that players keep
calm and they don't hit viewers
it's like it's really hard yeah it
really is coach you deal with it each
and every competition that your team's
face a Christian what's your advice uh
to our viewer yeah I think you have to
put things uh in a perspective as a
trustler and no good chess players are
good losers all of them hate themselves
hate their opponents hate chess hate
life after they lose a game but somehow
they put things in perspective and go to
the next game with a fresh mindset it's
all about uh the progression right the
trend has to be uh upwards the trends
cannot be down words right so this is
what you should be focused on but in the
middle you're going to see pigs and then
you're going to see values Peaks and
valleys Peaks and values and this is
what you are need to put things in
perspective and understand that there
will be losses and there will be wins
but overall you should have a positive
trend and you can only maintain a
positive trend with the positive
attitude this is how you should approach
it I remember the tanishqiri said that
one of the advices he got I think from
kramnik was just to focus on the next
game like really try to forget what
happened before and simply change your
focus change your mind and don't think
about the way you lost or what happened
there I think it's good thing to do
right I mean especially if you have to
play at the same day you really have to
kind of tell to yourself I will think
about it tomorrow well I tell you
there's so much really really great
advice like what you just said but it's
so hard to accept this advice it doesn't
work very well for me another plan
question from our social media but thank
you for that question It's just tough
uh from the film Gambit I like uh the
handle so the question is do you think
we'll ever see a king's Gambit in a
classical chess game in the US Chess
Championship or any other top level
tournament absolutely absolutely yes no
question about it well some people today
might think that the king's Gambit is
unplayable truly truly uh I I'm not one
of those players I think that the king's
Gambit is a risky yes but at some point
you just get into these uh situations
where a loss or a win you know is such a
asymmetric risk that you're willing to
take great risk and uh I I once lost to
Boris baskey and the candidates
tournament talk about a loss that was
tough and he's at the board and it was
like E4 E5 and he was doing this at the
board
like a tick tock and he's kind of going
back and forth with his head
and he played F4
and what a great game you won a great
game at the board and he was mentally
flipping the coin could he essay a
king's Gambit in the candidates
tournament and correct answer yes
oh that was painful that hurt that hurt
a lot
Christian can we see a king's Gambit in
the U.S Championship oh for sure we've
seen uh Knight takes E4 in the rui Lopez
yesterday
the Petra yeah we might as well see a
king's Gambit at some point in the
future as well but let's take a look at
what's happening in this very
interesting game between levonne aronian
and Wesley saw and uh of course at this
point you play the move King to H1 as
white you are focused on making F4
possible in position that's why you
start with the move G3 because once for
example if you play something like
Castle let's say F or take take you want
to take back with the pawn open up the G
file as well ideas of Rook to F3 Rook to
G3 coming into position F5 this is
looking really good for a white so what
does Wesley do after G3 hey you just
played G3 my Rook is still on h8 I might
as well try to take advantage of that H5
a very nice move by Wesley and after
some thought uh White played the move H4
counteracted this expansion with the
move H4 now F4 is going to be very
difficult to play right now because once
you play the move F4 this G4 Outpost
fortnite is going to be solidified in
the position you don't have any pawns to
attack it anymore so F4 not so easy to
make uh make it happen what I can do as
black is play the move Queen to D7 now I
have ideas of i2f4 here
for example if you play Bishop D2 boom
Knight F4 you take I give you a check
you go here and now I can make a draw if
I want but maybe I don't want to make it
wrong maybe I'm going to give you
Checkmate in a few moves right after
this move Knight to G4 you have to take
I take back with the pawn Rook takes H4
is coming this pin is very difficult to
deal with of course and if you try to go
Bishop to E3 after Rook to H4 Queen to
each one is going to come next move or
Quint wish to for that reason and uh the
game is over so you have to be very
careful after this move Queen to D7 most
likely yes we're going to see a defense
of this key Square H3 with the move King
to G2 and then still ideas maybe later
on of playing the move F4 a very
intriguing middle game is developing in
this one and you can rest assured both
of these players are enjoying this game
right now because it's very complex very
nuanced and there's a lot of options for
both sides to create imbalances in the
position and take a look at this
lifetime between these two players very
very close yes wins four wins for Lavon
three losses and 16 across
color history that was a good picture of
Levon I I can see Levon with some blonde
blonde tips of things speaking of hair
he really has that look like he just
fell out of the bed even like with the
hair better yes and today just pay
attention no flowers on his shirt
nothing that is foreign
by the way I I like the color and I like
the embroidery as well as we prepare for
a break uh tell us uh what are Q
Boutique specials are today at us we
have this athletic jacket today
chess club look at it it's very nice uh
heading to Fall in this athletic track
style zip up jacket featuring the Saint
Louis chess club logo it's available in
both men's and the women's Styles and
you can find it online right now at King
boutique.com I must say I love shopping
the other day because I knew I couldn't
have the slim fit or the straight fit
but the fit that works was the athletic
fit
America at the athletic fit so when I
saw you the athlete athletic that I
thought it must be be for me yes as we
go on a break we asked our lady players
their expectations for this U.S
Championship take a look and we'll see
on the other side of the break
[Music]
this is a very strong tournament
including a mix of young Thailand as
well as experience what are your
expectations about this tournament right
the tournaments get stronger younger
players are almost dominating and
overall my expectations are first of all
to play well and to be out to my own
standard and of course if I can get top
three that would be amazing too play
well
and scores importance I guess and that
was a game that's the goal and I've been
playing an instrument for many years and
I've had a lot of heartbreaks so at some
point I do want to claim the title I
just want to like play to the best of my
ability
um I'm not like putting a lot of
pressure on myself because this is my
first time playing and I perform better
like without pressure so it is kind of
weird because last time I was here I won
so I feel like any other like result
other than that would kind of be like
disappointing because it's like that's
that was a standard
um so I feel like that is what I'm
aiming for
um it is also kind of like a tough
tournament for me right now to not just
test wise but also because you know I'm
in schools I'm really trying to balance
everything as well like this is the
first time playing a tournament like
this in college
um so I'm just trying to you know do my
best
um like still maintain like my
schoolwork and you know just have like a
good time I don't come in this year with
big expectations uh it's great to see
some of the youngsters haven't done so
well in the past few years and having
progressed so much so I feel
just excited to play again and really I
think just the first year that I really
don't have any expectations I just want
to play good chess it's not easy time
like politically and I'm originally from
Ukraine and last like months I was busy
with other things
and uh I I'm trying to like recall how
good I was when I played when I won U.S
championships last years and I will try
to just repeat my results
like from past and I don't have like big
expectations and it's not easy answer
question to answer oh I think my
expectations are still the same as
they've always been you know to try to
do my best and if that works out
hopefully I can win my ninth title
um and yeah I still feel pretty good I
feel like I'm still in pretty good shape
just by getting uh you know older in
years
um well I just want to do my best since
my first year and like a lot of people I
have I have like watched and admired or
playing here so yeah it's a good
experience to um play against them
players should definitely getting
stronger and this year we also have more
players than usual 14 players it's also
getting younger I used to be one of the
younger ones not anymore my goal is
always to do my best and results will
just come so this is my first Year's
Women's Championship of course for my
expectations of course I want to try to
win foot with such a strong field it's
extremely hard for anybody so I think
more realistically I'd be happy with I
can even score especially since this is
like my first time playing it's always
great to get some experience I just want
to do my best as always in every
tournament
yeah I don't really have any super large
goals just try to play good chess
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back everyone round 10 of us
championships and we have the standings
in the women's section Jennifer Yume is
leading the field with six and a half
points and then Arena crush and Megan
Lee tied for the second place with six
points just a couple points behind the
leader it's a half a point in a very
very fragile lead as we've been
witnessing in the Women's Championship
and in the open
we have fagano Carana with six and a
half points same as 20 for you and then
Ray Robson is on the second place but
the difference is that they have a quite
a distance from the third place and the
one point between the werewolves and and
the group of players including linear
Dominguez Jeffrey drunk and all the
others yeah quite a chasing pack as we
are underway in this round 10 we're
seeing a kind of a repetition taking
place uh in the game between Levon and
Wesley and Lavon said I've had enough I
I'm going to play this move Mr Arbiter
and that will be a three-time repetition
as both players
not having a particularly stellar
result exactly it's funny how these top
players always find the repetition when
they want regardless of the position
right when they want to they will always
find it it's incredible yes it's a
mutual respect you know they say to each
other with this game like yeah I know
you're not having a great event and me
too but I'm not I'm not going to be the
one who will spoil it even more even
more I'm going to do it yes so both of
them decided to sign the piece and let's
say maybe still try to do something on
the last three rounds exactly they'll
have a free day tomorrow to do precisely
that to recharge their batteries and
take another look at these 2022
US championships let's jump to the game
of Fabiano and Christopher you because
we have seen something that well for all
of us we're rather stunned because Fabi
went into a 40-minute thing earlier in
the game and we didn't know if that was
a personal record a personal best or a
personal worst but whatever it was it he
there was something about the position
he didn't like and when did he do it
well right here this was the no no that
was not the moment yes this was actually
before the movement 35 minutes or was it
14. 40 minutes Anastasia my goodness so
40 40 minutes think to play a move that
as Christian said is the main move in
the position well Christopher happened
to be sitting at the board he answered
instantly Bishop D2 probably wondering
how did this guy win the U.S
Championship with a 40-minute thing on a
very well-known position King E7 Rook C1
Rook C8 Bishop E4 Knight before A3 all
of these moves are in fact Theory
castles inviting Bishop takes E2 no no
no no no don't even think about grabbing
this Pawn this will get you into a world
of trouble as as soon as the bishop
drops back there's a pin along the
e-file that will cost the piece on D5 so
you don't take he played Rook d8 now
threatening to take on E2 and I think
Rook C2 actually uh both Bishop F3
defending the pawn uh as well as Rook C2
there are games with these two moves and
we're expecting the theory to continue
from here yes sir yes but I was thinking
about not that you mentioned this 40
minute thing uh you know some players
they need to two minutes to finish the
games and in general yes like in general
in this one in this world and people are
not used to think you know sometimes
it's not only about remembering the
theory sometimes players really want to
go deeply into the position and kind of
remember and put to settle their mind in
order to kind of
um understand better like what's going
on right maybe you see this position not
that often and you try to remember what
are the main plans and ideas here maybe
something like this can happen but it's
really funny sometimes even my students
they ask like why what the hell he
thought was 15 minutes in this position
like what's going on with you how can
you spend so much time on one move right
and it's it's an interesting question
because these days people are not used
to think for so long I spend so much
time and calculate so deeply and are you
always calculating deeply or are you
thinking about hippo yeah about hippo or
you know some other
non-chess things going on in your mind
and I still love it I mean it's just a
brilliant brilliant moment in chess
history it was at a Hastings tournament
where Juan David bronstein one of the
world's most I want to say experienced
and knowledgeable theoreticians so in
the Soviet Union he wrote books he was a
Trailblazer in everything from the
king's Gambit to the king's Indian and
all stops in between if you ever look at
the Eco series and look at all the
footnotes regardless of the opening
there'll be an idea of David bronstein
anyway David branching he comes to a
game in Hastings I think this was the
50s they start his clock and he thinks
for 56 minutes on move one
then after the game the journalists
asked David what well Mr Rasheen what
what were you thinking about for 56
minutes on the first move and David who
knows everything about everything
said well I was thinking about what to
play
like it's just it's just great question
cracks me up man I was just thinking
about what to play yeah
it's so awkward so difficult can I get
an advantage here could I get an
advantage there I was thinking about
what to play what is going on what is
being played well actually Serena is in
trouble what exactly exactly that was my
response also when I saw the position
check this out so we left it somewhere
around here and we were saying that if
black doesn't win and I think you
mentioned this idea
I really like this move she decided to
go Rook to C1 okay that makes some sense
because one of uh Black's breaks in the
position is via B6 so it makes sense
that you're getting ready to put some
pressure on the pawn on C6 if things
happen on the queen side she decided to
go F6 Rochelle that is makes sense
Bishop takes F6 and now we've seen this
move Bishop takes F6 we will understand
what she missed in just a second what
she should have done is just play moves
such as Queen to D2 the battle it's all
about how will you react when black will
play the move E5 right and the response
to that is you have to immediately take
advantage of the fact that the pawn on
D5 uh is susceptible to an attack with a
move before I'm going to open up the
light squares I'm going to get the king
slowly but surely right not only that if
you take I also have this C4 Square to
maneuver and transition this knight from
A4 to C4 D6 wow this is what I want to
see in the position as y right so E4 is
key whenever black plays the move E5
okay now let's take a look at what
happened in the game Bishop takes F6
Knight takes F6 Queen to D4 this is what
she missed E5 now you're probably going
to have to take no I don't capture back
I play Knight to E4 and once again we
see this battle being lost by white
right now because you're not going to
play E4 anytime soon I'm going to take
with the queen back later on Queen takes
C5 and that's this Knight on uh E4 I'm
going to develop easily Bishop to F5
solidify and cement the Knight on e4
followed by the other Rook to E8
doubling up on the E file if we enter
that end game after the queen trade on
E5 this is going to be a clearly better
position for black better structure
you're a bit overextended on the queen
side you have a huge weakness on uh E3
and there's no way to attack my Pawns I
mean I might be in trouble right now I
really like this idea before how do you
meet E5 I mean if you ask this question
you can come out with this before idea
that is key you have to meet E5 with E4
wow so she missed it I like this queen
D2 and just saying okay your turn and
black is basically obliged in that
position to play E5 uh she's got
um sorry uh Rochelle's got all of her
and maybe Army pan out to see irina's
reaction right now because I do believe
that she is suffering and she
understands that she made a mistake
right now yes she appears to be
suffering actually she's not happy with
what just transpired in this game yes
right it doesn't take on the file
immediately probably trying to guess
maybe she can afford any other move like
move your her Queen back but this is
what you don't want to do after once you
played Queen D4 exactly and what is the
head to head between these two do they
match up with one another I'm sure we
played a number of times before really I
think the U.S championships
championships
three three games between them were uh
we'll double check the exact results uh
here
Purge missed opportunity for Irena
because agreed is still in a very
difficult position she's actually close
to uh losing right now of course still
plenty of play uh to be had in that one
but she's in trouble yeah let me know
let's just uh bring this game of Arena
and Rochelle up on our analysis board
for just a moment to show what an
important moment this is again uh
Jennifer's in trouble our tournament
leader Arena half a point behind Arena's
got a good position and from Black's
point of view look this Rook on E8 this
Knight on D7 this bishop on F6 Queen is
on C7 this is only one thing on Black's
agenda here and that is she's got to
play for e6e5 and after this
developing move it's a waiting move and
it just basically says to Black okay uh
what are you going to do well nothing
else to do but to play E6 E5 and this is
a very beautiful but hidden point after
this move E3 E4 you want to open up the
position with the Rook on B8 with the
bishop on C8 blast open the position so
you can play Bishop C4 check maybe on
the long diagonal good things can happen
too tactical things and open up the Rook
with the missed opportunity of that move
Queen D2 she took took Queen D4 E5 and
she must have just failed to realize
that Knight E4 is actually very very
strong black is going to win back the
pawn on her terms whether she takes with
the Rook or the queen and follow it up
with Bishop F5
everything is coming out uh roses for
arena Arenas just taken the pawn on E5
Christian we have a special guest in
studio yes we are with Levon aronian
very special very special very special I
want to welcome back to the show tell us
about today's game against Wesley it was
short but it was full of content
oh I'm not sure about the content of
course the position is very playable
because it's the end so I think this is
uh
variation that is maybe underestimated
because it's kind of interesting to play
with white this idea with E4 right yeah
yeah generally before and he responded
with probably the most topical line
Bishop to B4
yeah and uh
yeah I took a look at it sometime I
think the skin gauge one you know the
point is of King H1 is I want to meet
Knight D4 with B4
okay so you don't have this check yeah
and if you take you take on C5 yeah and
this is a good structure for me yeah
yeah that makes a lot of sense so here
black has many options I mean A6 Castle
A5
and in every case you have to play very
differently because with the pawn on A5
you can't afford to play Queen A1 but it
will Pawn only six all these lines are
very very dangerous because black and
long castle at some point and just start
the attack so in order for you to attack
you also have to be ready for him to
cast along with the pawn on A6 yeah but
not with the pawn on A5 yeah because the
pawn 95 is going to be hanging it's
going to be like some sort of a hook
a3b4 you know a knight goes somewhere
might be 595 yeah yeah this time makes a
lot of sense and you play this move
Queen to E1 Knight D4 Bishop D1 very
nice uh regrouping G3 and how he came up
with this yeah I think aggressive H5
it's not aggressive it's more
strategical because if black castles
then F4 is very unpleasant not an F5 G4
this type of things F5 G4 and if you
take of course take and Rook F3 Rook G3
yeah
this is not looking good
and he played H5 you responded were you
by the way still in your preparation no
no I thought you know if I play uh
if I play F4 I thought well you know
after 96 that was an interesting moment
I thought that four is the most topical
and then uh he probably has to take EF
because if Knight F4 Bishop F4 e e f and
E5 I E5
and thanks 0.65 and if Queen is seven
Bishop A4
C6 through K1
yeah yeah and he cannot play Bishop E3
because I take and Rook F4 she cannot
take because of rookie one up and maybe
1955 the game is over yeah that's very
nice actually
yeah everything comes with Tempo yeah so
it's I thought it's very very dangerous
to take with the night but I rejected it
mainly on the grounds so you take Kev
yes
yes and uh well now I cannot take Bishop
before Knight F4 no more E5 yeah so I
have to play Knight D5
and here I felt Castle
and then you know Knight F4 Knight F4
Bishop F4 and Bishop D4 actually before
Mike should be fine here so it's a very
strong Bishop on D4 protecting the king
side as well and you play the move G3 no
I felt that G3 is not the way to go but
somehow I felt that therefore there's
nothing so I didn't really remember what
I was planning to do here
and here yeah you know
um application for C5 I mean Bishop D4 I
think is the right setup because the
point is
he wants to meet F4 with Knight C5
and then uh you know it's kind of
awkward I have to defend this pawn and
then he might try for a four two and
then a four a three ideas yeah
so F4 I don't think is a very
and you're actually not that fast on
this side either it seems like um yeah
yeah with your of course I I can do it
on move number 14 you know instead of
King G2
play it for here Bishop maybe if I was
to play F4 of course I had to do it here
but then Bishop D4 same I'm also not so
sure I'm I'm really doing any progress
here on on the king side F5 Knight C5
once again yeah F5 is logical and if
Knight E2 he can always play Bishop C5
he's also waiting you know
so maybe I can play it with Knight G1
but I wasn't not so sure
some strategical position black can you
know try to play Knight D4 and Knight G4
I mean if if I was in a in a better uh
shape I would definitely
you know try to
play on and create some battle but at
this moment I'm trying to minimize the
damage what would you say is the main
factor that caused let's say it is
dropping shape for you oh I think I
played too much at some point it was
yeah it made me tired so I just need
some
I think a week of rest I'm back on back
on a horse
for sure and tomorrow actually is a rest
day what are you going to do during the
rest day what's the plan
oh just uh you know walk around maybe uh
you know go for a little jog stuff like
that absolutely guys any questions for
uh Levant no absolutely Lavon uh get
your rest recharge your batteries come
out strong for the last three rounds
we're not going to make lemon tart
you're not gonna torch no absolutely uh
Wu did play that move Knight E4 the very
move that Arena likely feared and I I'm
saying wow what a huge missed
opportunity here for uh Arena because
she had a I think a very nice advantage
that Advantage is gone and why is that
so important because Jennifer you I
don't like Jennifer's position in in her
game
with Naji last move after d76 White's
King still stuck in the center if she
wanted she could have captured this pawn
and you know been prepared to maybe E5
and something like E4 blast open the
king in the middle of the board careful
careful of course I could play Queen
takes D6 as well but Jennifer said well
I'm going to shut down this bishop I'm
going to play the move C5 takes and I
think now it's got to be H3 if there's
no if there's no H3 well I'm I'm worried
for Jennifer that Queen D5 and C4 is
just killing like uh again like a H3 do
you have like C4 no in this kind of
thing let's take a look is there some
jaw material right
I didn't see it immediately no I also I
don't see it but but there's nothing
particularly
with Knight H6
yeah if you could get your knight to F5
into E4 you're just you're just so much
better with uh with the black pieces
right out of the opening by the way I
always look for that too I noticed that
you had asked me about geometry and then
in the game between Sabina and uh Rue
Yang Yan
I just like these four nights
the Cavalry the Cavalry is coming right
uh whites nights on these squares D4 E5
blacks Knights on these squares F5 uh E4
I don't know what's going on in the game
it was just that that caught my eye I'll
show you some nice things
yeah and this game between uh back in
with the black pieces and ashrita this
last move Knight to F4 check out this
line I've been uh toggling through the
variations Queen to D1 seems to be the
best move but you just played the move
Queen to G4 so psychologically Queen to
D1 is an extremely difficult move to
make now if you play the move Rook 81
and try to defend like this you're in
trouble because Queen is actually
getting trapped right or at least almost
uh trapped Queen to F3 Knight to D4 you
take on D4 I take back with the E Pawn I
can even start with the move G4 first
but of course take with the E Pawn and
then uh G4 might be problematic for your
queen so for example Knight V2 G4 where
do you put the queen you probably have
to go here I follow it up with Rook 28
you're in trouble right yes you're going
to lose the queen so this one is over
now what can you do to my eyes Knight to
E3 makes the most sense Queen to D1 I'm
even going to cancel that move I don't
think is going to land on the board
because psychological is just so
difficult to make Queen G4 and then go
back to uh D1 so I'm expecting something
along these lines
right and now if you play the move Rook
81 yes right this is the geometry that
I'm talking about
E4
you cannot talk take with the Knight
because I'm taking on B to a full piece
you cannot take with a pawn because
Bishop takes C3 and oops there is a
check there
Knight takes C3 this is key very very
nice position and very nice ideas for uh
black with this Knight landed on F4 so
Knight to E3 is on the board right now
we're expecting Rook to F7 there's I
don't think there's any other move Rook
to F7 was played of course most likely
we're going to see Queen takes D7 and
then well white is going to have to be
very careful because Rook 81 uh at that
move E4 is extremely aggressive and it's
not going to be easy to challenge that
in the position let's see what ashrita
comes up with as a defensive mechanism
in this one yeah it seems like the uh
was uh mistimed uh just turning our
attention to Megan and Talia for a
moment this was this sharp night or
party yeah
h3g4 Bishop E3 Knight A5 I uh often
times this night on C6 is in the way but
once it goes to A5 it hopes to land on
the C4 Square so Megan said well I don't
want to see that happening uh Knight
takes A5 Queen takes A5 Queen D2 B5
castles B4 uh and I've up to date with
the play now this idea of forcing white
to occupy the D5 square is great from a
strategic point of view I get that
everything's nice for black so you look
just a little bit deeper at the moment
whites Bishops are pretty good you know
kind of open and give me the move and
I'm ready to play a2a3 and maybe you
would rather have traded queens and
maybe left your Pawn at home on B7 so
there are things for white to nibble on
a2a3 she will get the better structure
for example if you do something like
castles A3 Rook B8 and then again I'm
just putting moves on the board to try
to
show what I'm thinking about we get all
this position and this is the you know
yeah better a better Pawn structure I
want to say for white it's easier for
white to attack the A6 Pawn than maybe
the C2 Pawn so for the moment I'm
thinking that uh in this game of cat and
mouse uh who's out Fox 2 for the moment
I think Megan is doing quite well I
think we don't pay attention that much
to open Event okay there are some games
we never checked to tell me where would
you like to take us Anastasia let's
check the game because I will keep an
eye on it between Hans uh he plays um
yes I mean suffering Elsa maybe Hans got
some chances because I think his
position looks quite quite good looks
like he sold his problems with black
pieces at the moment it's funny I'm
looking at these two minor pieces I look
at this bishop on D4 and I say what a
magnetism
it looks great but then I look at this
Knight on e4 and I said wow what a
magnificent night so two offsetting
pieces and okay I saw earlier it was a
game with H6 G5 Bishop got chased to G3
the Knight went to H5 and took on G3
um what's your first take do you like
Black's position do you like White's
position I'm just I I really like this
bishop actually because so you're
attracted like we'll go before and uh
goes to the before I mean I'm normally
very happy diagonal seems to be mine
nobody is really trying to make a new
problems for me exactly well you know
it's one of those things you know you've
got your trumps I've got my trump so in
a position where we both have mutual
charms one of the things that I like to
do is I I like to look at the Strategic
factors for just a moment yes I'm seeing
that you're Bishop on D4 and I'm going
whoa whoa whoa whoa that is really
really an impressive Bishop right so the
bishop hits F2 and B2 but now here's the
key
the bishop can't do it by itself he
needs help he needs the help of The Rook
it needs the help of The Rook so whether
you're going whether your target is B2
or F2 your Rooks have to help the bishop
Target so I really really like the move
by elshon Rook to 83. what that move
says to me it's a neutralizing move I
see so as soon as you go Rook f8 guess
what I'm trying to do three probably
Rook F I have three okay I'm trying to
neutralize the doubled Rooks and to take
away the sting of your attack on the
pawn on B2 conversely let's say you had
played the move B5 yes this is was
another possibility right yes I might
just play the move rookies three okay so
what's my idea here well I want to
neutralize yourself
good morning
don't hang the Rook but yes that that
was why I like the move uh Rook A3 by
elshon with this idea and the key is I'm
going to either neutralize your play on
the B file if you initiate the play with
B5 or if you play Rook f8 I want to
initi play Rook and then that's it very
easy for yeah that's exactly right
that's why and it's so easy to you know
sometimes the Grandmasters play are so
logical oh well
I'm going to play this and I'm going to
stop you so the move G5 G4 now the
question for L shot is you're taking
away Rook F3 from you I have to make my
own play maybe I will play now the move
Rook V3 why because I'm trying to keep
you honest I don't want to see you
double your Rooks I want to make it cost
you a pawn if you're going to go after
my king you know like you have to make
an investment and is it possible to play
Rook effect yesterday seven do you
really want to take one of two it looks
like no you have three pieces I think in
four pieces defending yes that's a lot
of Defenders yes I don't know what else
you can do here like can you still try
to do something like H5 H4 G3 precise he
has come to my mind like yeah that's a
plan I agree with you wholeheartedly uh
one of the things is you your Queen's
kind of okay defense G4 defense H6 but
you kind of like to feel like the queen
could do more yes and if you could get
your Pawn to H4 and your Rook to E3 kick
away this Knight maybe you could fly
before because this might take so
registry the queen takes just
responsible sometimes right so I like
your idea of H5 and uh we'll see
whose aggression is uh paying off and as
always thank you so much for joining our
show and challenging our panel we have a
question we have a question from social
media
Henry the geese the guys the guys yes
would like to know yes so dear yes sir
it's a question for you yes sir what
steps on or actions do you recommend to
do for Preparation a week before an
event like us like a U.S Chess
Championship a day before a match and a
few hours before a match exactly I thank
you very much for the question Henry
because I think already once you get
that window of a week uh it's over
whatever training you needed to do you
needed to do before that week or before
that day or before that hour the best
thing you can do is clear your mind you
don't want to be
overwhelmed with so much preparation
that you're actually going to the board
tired and that happens to a lot of
players you will hear their complaints
like Arena was complaining to us last
night at dinner that her preparation is
so intense that she's not coming to the
games with enough energy so at a certain
moment you just have to shut down this
whole idea you say to yourself I've done
the best preparation I can I want to go
to the gym I want to take a walk as uh
just prescribed by Lavon and to say
recharge my batteries because sometimes
you're just out of energy it's just too
much yes I know actually
was telling me that sometimes she would
spend like eight hours to prepare for
the game I mean can you imagine yeah sir
this is too hard and I've seen those
suppliers running like 15 minutes before
the round to check with the trainer
something else like unbelievable you
know it's maybe sometimes it's just also
lack of confidence something what you
said yes like you may really need to
stop at certain point and but still
there are some tricks yes sir maybe you
used some of those tricks when you were
active player like
um what would you do like kind of make
your brain work to work yes uh one of
the things I liked to do and uh asking a
number of my colleagues it was funny we
liked studies we like just solving
studies like calculating but they had to
be pretty they had to bring us a smile
it wasn't something we did for work it
was something that we just
a switch to turn on our brains a little
okay I mean if you do nothing if you
watch TV then you're kind of a passive
you're not in there and that's why I
really understand why a lot of chess
players are Gamers like the video games
because they like being actively
involved in decision making stuff like
that
um got akamski he didn't mind playing a
few Blitz Games okay you'd like to warm
up with a few billets or bullet games he
would come to a U.S Championship with
some feeling that he knew how to move
the pieces So Different Strokes for
different folks whatever works for you
but yeah don't overdo it that Anna
really overdid it yes I think eight
hours that's just like then you then you
just drained at that time she was like
18 or 90 she could still afford you know
right she had the energy yeah yeah it
was too much Christian what do you
recommend uh to do before the game uh
when when do you pull parachute and say
no more or prep
well recently yes recently for example
in the case of Beckham jonova okay she
was struggling because we were doing a
lot of preparation we still are doing a
lot of preparation so usually the way
our day's work is after she finishes the
game we actually meet sometime around
9pm after dinner and we try to do a
couple of hours of preparation at least
try to figure things out uh figure out
the direction of where the game could
potentially go and then she goes on and
she repeats her lines and that usually
takes her towards midnight and that
that's when I tell her at midnight you
have to go to sleep midnight is the end
time and after that at 10 A.M in the
morning the next day she comes back she
repeats but in the recent games and
things weren't working that well for her
in this tournament because it wasn't
that much about the opening phase of the
game but she was consuming a lot of
energy in preparation but not having a
lot of energy in the critical moments in
her games and that's when I told her
okay we're going to slow things down
when it comes to preparation we're only
going to do things maybe for one hour at
night and one hour in the morning and
then you repeat on your own time try to
take some walks that's very very
important especially after the game to
release some tension and get your energy
back I think that's quite uh critical
and of course around one hour before the
round starts you shouldn't be looking at
any computer screens try to take a break
from that and right now by the way
speaking of this game things have
matured in the position in fact they
followed just the line that we were
discussing
yeah yeah begum has one upon I want to
turn sorry honestly did you want to jump
in Jennifer for example I know that she
goes to gym after the games it's also
one of the possibilities
like frustrations exactly some players
they do this but but it's a great great
idea if you can if that appeals yeah
Christian just said about the
preparation it seems like five hours
they were preparing before wow
[Music]
combined combined by night time in the
morning and if you take into account
that sometimes five six hours wow that
was a lot it's a heavy day yeah but now
we're entering the final stages of the
event and energy levels should be
prioritized exactly yes because at the
beginning you have energy right you've
done your work before you've went to the
gym before the tournament you're in
tipped up shape hopefully you're in
tipped up shape and all you have to do
is kind of have your preparation ready
or your openings uh ready and get a good
game out of the opening towards the end
the final stages of the event you have
to prioritize energy levels yeah I would
just say one thing about the whole
question that Henry asked about
preparation and this is very important
is that I came to the games
with this idea that I had an idea I had
an idea for the preparation and I was
confident yes the moment I have that you
know like build up of like I've got the
energy I'm confident I come to the game
and this was really really funny I I I
had the game between Christopher you and
Bobby on my screen but I think it's a
hilarious moment in my chess career
and I went the world team championship
in China and we're playing against
Azerbaijan I'm on light board three I
basically retired from chess and I was
saying to my dear friend John Donaldson
the team captain you know like I take it
easy on me you know I I I I I haven't
played in a while you know don't feed me
a lot of blacks he started me with three
blacks
it was really really cool I mean the St
Louis chess club the Scholastic Center
is going to help our team so they sent a
coach now all of my team members are
super Pros man they got their databases
they got their files Yaz is in trouble
but the coach was Ben Feingold so this
was great so Ben would come to my room
at about 10 in the morning and then stay
till 11 I kick him out we could then go
have lunch and it was really great so
none of our preparation ever ever
happened yes that was that was the first
good news but Ben in that 10 that one
hour that 60 minutes from 10 and 11 got
me in the right frame of mind like oh I
got this great idea for you yes or you
play like this and you'll nail the guy
you go here here here here okay I'll do
it then and I never got the position
so I was playing we would it was a t it
was Azerbaijan and there I am on board
three and the as series
sandbagged oh yes they put their number
one player on board three shakuria
Madara was the highest rated player they
put him on board three so I gotta play
Shack so in those days Shaq was playing
grunfels so there we were for one hour
busting grunfeld after grunfeld and in
two moves I was badly out prepared
that I'll prepare it he played C5 I
played D5 and he played F5 ah this is so
I'm stirring my coffee and I'm looking
at the position I'm saying this is the
strangest looking group felt I've ever
seen in my life this is not a green
thought but the whole point was that I
had he Ben had got me into that right
state state of mind that I was confident
I could do anything and beat anybody and
that's when I played E4 tags Knight C3
Knight F6 G4 and blue Shaq off the board
let's go it wasn't the grunfeld but it
was this idea that the prayer
preparation stops
when you just have that confidence that
that that that
this is this is what I can do no matter
what happens now because it's really
frustrating sometimes right when you
start the game and all your five hours
of preparation are gone yes so you have
to kind of put yourself together again
now I would like to turn to Christopher
you and Fabby for just a moment to say I
am really really impressed by the 15
year old Christopher you because in my
estimation he's completely tricked Fabi
like the computer may say even yes you
know zero zeros and stuff and I go no no
no no no if I'm in Christopher's shoes
I see the split pons versus my B3 and A3
and I say you know that's one for me
that's a that's an edge on my side of
the table because uh your pawns are
split which means they're a little bit
more vulnerable uh that's the first
thing the second thing is two Rooks two
Rooks well who's attacking who's
defending Ah that's also in my favor the
knights will more or less balanced but I
would just ask this night on DC B6 how
it's feeling like it's how many places
are gonna go so good and lastly and this
is very very important Christopher you
is like 200 rating points lower or maybe
100 rating points lower than 5B what
could be better than having a position
where you have
is 200 plus 200 something yeah 200 plus
so wow what you know how great it is to
be in a position you're slightly better
but this is what we discussed at the
beginning of this end game if white
manages to get this structure a B versus
AC double up uh that works on the C file
and black doesn't get the move C4 right
try to exchange those uh pawns right
white is just simply going for a very
long time it's going for a very long
time a disadvantage for the next 20 30
moves right and at some point usually I
I will win the C5 Pawn in the end I mean
you're going to have to whenever you
move the Knight by the way I go B4 right
and that might be problematic so if you
go 97 B4 not only that but if you give
me one more move I'm not even
considering taking maybe I go B5
followed by Knight to C6 yes why is that
light lands on C6 I can switch uh files
from C to D with my Rooks and invade via
d8 you might be in serious danger in
that situation so this one is a
difficult decision and a difficult
defense for Fabiano caruana which is
this one which is something very very
unique for this tournament for probably
because Fabi has been cruising not just
his victories which have been Splendid
in power to him but even in the draws
he's been on the Sunny Side this is the
first time we see Fabi maybe in a
position that's unfavorable and dare we
say it if Christopher like defeated the
defending Champion
it opens up the door for Ray Robson and
that host of gangsters you've been
talking about it in the trailing packs
yesterday if you play for example King
G6 like I'll
so the geometry again if it works no
it's beautiful
that's really getting them from behind
97 and a lovely Fork the king would have
to give up the protection of the rook
and you've just yeah you just grab the
Palm yes so just just in this example if
you try to for example bring your king
into the centers since the psychological
move right but then there is a street
corruption part exactly those tactics
you've got to be careful even in the
ending tactics and by the way I like
this move also h2h3 by Christopher he
gives himself the flexibility of playing
for F4 and he says to Black if you play
G4 you know I'll bring my king into the
center and it's quite possible this Pawn
on G4 is
more of a liability than an asset so
we're going to keep an eye on this one
as Fabi for the first time in the
tournament might be well is suffering
and again this was the game he had the
40-minute thing maybe he suspected very
early on that he was walking into a
position that he shouldn't and he played
this move Bishop B4 check only after 30
minutes of thought Christian uh back
over to you and what has caught your eye
I'm looking at the ladies section and
this game of baggy man ashrita
this is the position so we saw this move
E4 come on the board night wave 4
actually was ashrita's defense take on
D3 with the pawn G3 Force the Knight to
enter uh White's position via E2 but now
this is a nice transition Square because
I'm headed towards the center on D4 it
makes a lot of sense Rook 2 f8 so she's
definitely hinting at the fact that she
will be putting a lot of pressure on the
f file and Bishop takes G7 right now was
played Rook to D3 was another option
Bishop takes you this is a critical
moment right now because once again we
talk about geometry and tactics in the
position and black has this move which
is by the way not very natural I have to
say Rook takes G7 yes not King takes G7
and now after Rook takes D3 it looks
like sure but what and she did play King
takes G7 which once again makes a lot
more sense than Rook takes G7 if you
look at it from a human's perspective
the key was that if you take on G7 and
take on D3 I have this move yes check
foreign
you take take you move the night the
king somewhere King to F1 I pick up on
E3 but I can also start with the move
Knight to E5 once again everything comes
with Tempo and my Rooks are perfectly
placed uh to create a vicious attack if
you go Rook to C3 I pick up this guy and
then I go Knight to G4 both your H2 and
F2 pawns are under attack you cannot
defend both you're in big big trouble
right now with the white pieces so this
Knight on May 4. we've missed
opportunity indeed for a begging she
took with the Knight right now Rook
takes D3 most likely is going to come on
the board it makes the most sense and
still after Knight to D4 it is uh White
that needs to find the defensive
mechanism nevertheless she improved her
position a little bit uh black had much
better ideas in the position still
happened black to be preferred in this
one right let's wait and see and she is
putting some pressure on her clock as
well ashrita is playing very quickly her
moves right
um just turning our attention to the
game between a Wonder Liang and Lanier
Dominguez this chasing pack of players
who are on the outside looking in hoping
that Fabi stumbles as well as Ray Robson
this was the game between the two
Knights versus the two Bishops and in
Seattle uh University of Washington Marv
Harshman was the the basketball coach
and he was asked why he always recruited
tall players he said well Tall players
remain tall short players who are fast
get tired why do we like the two Bishops
because as the position opens the
Bishops begin to really enjoy the
diagonals more diagonals for the Bishops
and it's inevitable that there will be
Pawn trades and inevitably the Bishops
will start to bloom that's what I'm
seeing in the game between Lanier and a
Wonder at the moment I think the game is
still don't give me wrong very very
balanced but I am seeing the the
that the Bishops like for example
imagine I would play a move like Bishop
B4 in this position I can see that you
could for example and let's say I take
and take and this is where this bishop
is kind of blooming if you will for just
a moment there's a pin yeah I understand
that the game is still very very even
but you start to see that the bishop is
uh well again it's
it's wrong to say taking over but you
but my point about the Bishops improving
is uh being seen also I just wanted to
go where are you Jeffrey Zhang versus
Sam Shanklin you know the U.S Olympic
team and you heard Ray Robson say you
know like that so it was a really goal
of this to be on a medal winning U.S
Olympic team you get on the U.S Olympic
team I gotta tell you you're in a pack
of a great company you you like actually
being with these guys the fact that you
even managed to make the difference
with the place no with the players we
have well Jeffrey Zhang and Sam Shanklin
are both those bubble players if you
will they're just you know like trying
to make that fifth spot on our Olympic
teams they're going up against each
other and it's more than just you know
the U.S Championship it's more than
rating it's sort of like hey you know
we're jockeying for Olympic team
placement as well well this position
the players have again we're seeing
these kind of like Queens Gambit
accepted kind of positions now it it it
it changed though the structure changed
dramatically when Sam decided to
recapture with a bond isolating his Pawn
I think thanks to that decision I like
Jeffrey's position because of that
decision I want to say isolating the
e-pawn I would if I were white I'd
probably just get get out of this
potential opinion and just ask black are
you are you going to try to Target my
Pawn on B5 well don't do that I've just
defended it and I'm I'm warming up to
Jeffrey again Jeffrey's coming into
today's round undefeated yes plus one
plus one uh looking for more Christian
back over to you well I'm looking and
you might actually be wondering why
we're not giving prime time this game
between Sam Savion and Ray Robson it's
not because Ray Robson is well he is
only half a point behind the leader so
by that metric we should definitely
looking be looking at the game but the
position is just so dry he equalized
with the black pieces white he's not
really trying to do much most likely
this one is just going to end up in a
draw very quickly what I'm saying is
King f8 King E7 at some point I'm going
to take on C1 follow it up with Rook to
C8 we're going to see uh the bishop m
game in which none of the players have
any real chances right at actually
making a dent in their opponent's
position so this one is headed towards
the draw so the big game Remains the one
between Christopher you uh and Fabiano
caruana in which Christopher is
definitely making some astrides and
putting a lot of pressure on our leader
actually we took the pressure on the
leader yes both of them yes yes
so actually in case the father loses
this game uh then he Ray Robson will
catch him on the first position right
assuming that Ray draws which seems to
be the Assumption at the moment as uh
but I really like what Fabi did right
with this move F5 and King to F6 it
seems like he at least is getting more
active in the position
H3 he played f55 yeah yeah
F5 King E3
Christopher still plays very very
quickly in this game King history was
the idea that if you take only four I
will take with the king and you will
have this E6 weakness another right yes
so of course black cannot do it it leads
the charge at some moment
um
I I'm I really desperately want to play
this movie before uh you mentioned it a
moment ago that uh the night could come
to C6 when the King was on E7 the night
hopping the C6 was far more attractive
now playing the move B5 I'm seeing I've
got issues here it's not so that easy
well I
yeah no I'm I think I'm going down a
dead a rabbit hole there so without B4
maybe you can take deep file right now
or it's not possible just to swing oh
yes but I think then C4 or what yeah I
think that was the problem that
Christian was mentioning uh here yes I
could be very uh Savvy and move my Rook
uh back to that actually we have to
check this variation until the end which
maybe you can take C to xb3 no I'm
joking of course but it was just a
woman's chicken this kind of life oh
that's sweet
you've just made a new girl uh look at
this nice nice
yeah I like it I love it in fact I would
have to try to Swindle a draw
uh but okay uh huge huge game uh and in
the balance hangs our lead going into
our rest day we have a question from our
audience Anastasia let's uh let's
prepare let's brace yes for an incoming
question ready for questions this one is
from people yes
that's good and Christian is there any
chance you will invite Hans to your
podcast in order to hear once and for
all Hans speak for himself
is he uh is he a likely victim uh you
guys are starting uh to uh start the pot
trying to write some problems that's our
job yeah look we we will invite uh Hans
at some point uh and we will see whether
he will accept to come but it's unclear
whether he wants to do that it doesn't
seem like right now he wants to make too
many statements let's just put it that
way well well just to remind everyone
our viewer you and Fabi have created c
squared a podcast of the Chess World
you're you're talking about the latest
and greatest things that are going on
and right now it is the major
controversy and you've had a number of
guests including Alejandro Ramirez
and what and yourself and myself well
I'm not the guy to ask yourself I'm not
the guy to ask about the computers and
all of that good stuff I know nothing
um what's what's the feedback then from
your viewers oh the feedback has been uh
great I think uh the podcast has been
received quite well and of course if you
want to go check it out you will find it
on YouTube and all the other platforms
but I don't think we should sell it too
much
not too much modesty becomes you uh
you're a very modest man with much to be
modest about so
and we have another question uh
Anastasia
let's see what we have
and here it comes from Martin CFC that's
very official looking yes so we have a
question do you have to be in the chess
club to join feeder chess tournaments I
have only played online and really want
to try to achieve a fitted title Someday
my answer to the question is no you
don't necessarily have to join the chess
club but it would really really behoove
you to join your National Federation the
national Federation is really the member
let's be clear what fide is fide is an
international body and its members are
not Anastasia and myself its members are
federations so the United States Chess
Federation in my case the Ukrainian
Chess Federation it speaks to the fide
on our behalf so if you wanted to make a
feed a title your Federation would have
to petition fide and say look we've got
this wonderful promising player over
here please I recognize them for their
success so really join your National
Federation wherever it is that you may
be and good luck on your title that's
great and on tournaments okay first we
should start to play in the offline
events and then step by step you can do
it also I think there are some online
there is a video online Arena where you
can make online right that's right which
is a little bit still different case
awkward I mean yeah you should still I
think try to be overboard titles that
they they take precedent but yes it
depends on you maybe sometimes people
don't have time to play offline events
then you have a good alternative in this
case exactly uh turning to our chess uh
question for a moment you said you like
that fevy played F5 and King F6 against
Christopher you I kind of like
Christopher's position I just don't know
it's exactly how he should increase his
Advantage if I can speak in those terms
I'm not exactly sure how big his
Advantage might be but how could
Christian how could Christopher increase
his Advantage what should he be playing
for well it seems like he actually lost
all his advantages he played F4 yes
before in opening up the G file might
actually backfire in this position
um it seems like you actually have to be
very precise not to be worse that's why
right now wow okay so you have to think
back with the g-pawn it seems like and
then most likely I'm going to continue
by taking the other Pawn as well and
continue right and now maybe this move
H4 and this is quite a nice move quite a
critical move it's all about this dance
of if you move the Rooks I can move my
Rook right because you ease the tension
on C5 if you move the Knight I can
exchange or I can move my own Knight
because you is the tension as well in
the position so it's this dance in which
uh it doesn't seem like this F4 came on
the board whoa
wow that was an example that's not good
that is
that was what I was afraid of and if you
take on C5 maybe you're already actually
much worse right now take on C5 you take
on C5 and then I take 24 uh or G3
guys this is not looking good and it
seems like Christopher is hurrying up to
get to this position he's not taking his
time and uh he has uh let Fabiano Hikaru
off the hook and maybe even worse right
now with the white pieces yeah I was
going to say I didn't like the move F4
but I was kind of grasping
towards you for a question how
Christopher should have played instead
of I didn't like the move F4 no no no F4
was a bit too much and in fact it was
just about Fabiano's very very
level-headed play yes this move F5 and
trying to create his own chances was
quite important
um at this point though what white
should have done was take advantage of
the fact that you created some new
weaknesses right by overextending on the
king side and try to exchange the
knights with the move Knight to C4
um take advantage of the fact that the
pawn is still on e4 and you don't have a
way to run away from uh to uh positively
run away from this exchange with the
move Knight to D5 you have to stay
passive if you want to do so but then
unfortunately after this trade you have
some problems on the D file right with
an ID it's all about the uh over
extension Rook to D1 Rook to D2 uh is an
option as well it's obvious to the naked
eye that white is just simply better
right at this point so
yeah this was the critical move Knight
to C4 and if we see this trade once
again we understand if you take I take
35 coming this guy this guy this guy as
well they're all very very weak in the
position so you will be struggling with
the black pieces in this particular
structure he did not play that he
allowed Fabiano to activate his King
with the move King to F6 which was a
critical uh part of his idea and now
whenever you take I also have this check
on D5 yeah I think it's not good on E3
it's not great at all and uh King to F4
this is the position we have right now
it's still balanced but I mean if you
make two or three more bad moves with
the black pieces you might end in uh
some real danger to lose this one as
Christopher you wow thank you for that
as Anastasia as we get ready for break
let's just remind our viewers that we do
have one result already in the open
section between
and the other games are still on the way
and we will be back soon
see you on the other side of the break
everyone
[Music]
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spassky match examining their early
lives and careers leading up to their
classic match you can join John live on
October 18th at the World Chess Hall of
Fame or watch the live stream on the
World Chess Hall of Fame YouTube channel
that's October 18th John Donaldson live
more information at stlouischessclub.org
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the World Chess Hall of Fame in St Louis
is nothing you'd expect and everything
you love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the World
Chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are on round 10 of us championships
and current standings for women's
section Jennifer Yu is leading with six
half six and a half points right but her
position doesn't look that great so
Arena Crush together with Megan Lee
shared the second place trailing only by
a half a point Alice Lee looked on the
outside looking in as well and in the
open section we have one result and in
the open section we have the result
between Lebon aronian and Wesley so they
made a draw and all the other games
continue absolutely and let's just jump
right into it in the game between
Christopher you and Fabiano uh again we
don't want to get two of uh far ahead of
ourselves when hyperbole but so much is
at stake in this one game
Christopher we like this position before
he played King E3 and F4 and we thought
that already after takes takes E5 check
Fabi would be well ever so slightly for
Choice Bobby made a decision I found a
little confounding he took on e4 took an
E4 and dropped back with his King and
I'm kind of looking at the position and
I'm saying everything I see on the
boards okay
a little bit more free a little bit more
active and I noticed by the way haha yes
you have some classical training in your
Anastasia because you use the word
Islands ah yes yes yes
and you look at the position there's
four Pond Islands Four black two Pond
islands for white so maybe Christopher
is back with a slight pull again I I'm
just thinking this night on A5 is a
little bit offsides now and I would try
to redirect my Knight Knight c49 E5 is
one idea and I can always make a passer
Christopher again maybe a little bit
straightforward impulsive here it has
not patiently played the position played
G4 and guess what I mean uh Fabi said
well there goes one of my Pawn islands
and I think things are back into let's
say normalcy balance but I can't help
but mention the very nice tactic you
pointed out quite some time ago it still
exists if you want to come back to the
D6 Square I got you uh Knight B7 check
and that'll hurt your feelings so I have
a feeling Christopher just wants to make
a draw
this is what I kind of feel maybe I'm
wrong I'm not convinced yes not
convinced yeah no we we have in the
center no no why why you guys think he
wants to make a draw I don't know the
move G4 doesn't show a lot of ambition I
thought Knight C4 95 was I think it's
okay with a draw yes like I wanted to
make a draw I think he's still a Harbors
some hopes that he can potentially
create some problems for his opponent
okay in this position and it's not that
easy I mean you still have some moves to
go until you're completely safe as black
okay
let's try to play this one just in case
I take on C5 yes this is what I thought
no no that's problematic I think well
just to make sure how you can go wrong
yes
for example
with Check Yes more than that so Rook 65
immediately okay and then let's trade it
if we trade then Rook G4 checks three
and
exactly well is it the end of the story
I mean I go Rook G7 if you go night
check
I'll turn the tables uh and if you go
Rook check I'm still I mean the the
reduce material is so it's very reduced
that that that's true that's true so
maybe this one is close to equality
let's go Knight C6 let's keep going okay
okay just seven that's just six
uh-huh all we have is time yes yes okay
this night ending we know that if King
is so I would I I'm reluctant to
I'm a bit worried for black in that
position by the way you are after Knight
C8 just kidding before King E4 King F6
of course and now maybe King D4 and King
D4 now I have killed this I know I don't
know
that's the problem I don't see your next
move that's fine and now I go B4 and you
just kind of like uh press a little bit
over there I still don't see your next
move because A6 is met with Knight B8 if
I manage to get my Pawn to A6 as well as
b56 sorry A6 sorry 98 96 now I want to
play 94. okay you play for but if you
take the phone yeah I will take it it's
just gonna take some time
I mean anytime you move your night away
I've got okay
we're off we're we're really down the
rabbit hole on this one but the point is
is that uh by the way he's making F6
back King how do we feel about that move
um now he's going towards G5 is that his
plan oh why not
although it's strange it's strange I I
really thought that uh Fabi should be
bringing his Knight back into the game
and something like Knight D7
preparing to move the Rooks but okay
King F6
nothing's wrong with that move it's an
interesting move right now for uh White
in fact after king of six G5
and then can get five of us yeah
checkmate
upset
Fabiano well I tell you once you see G5
with the concept of King takes G5 King
E5 uh all your adrenaline starts pumping
and you get yourself really excited
because that is a very pretty no because
like you've tried to run away and you
play King G6 and then Rook of two
how far are you running right yes and
actually your piece is kind of
um I mean it's sort of like you start to
run which is in a very strange way you
run into the corner so that you just
you're just in time to to block the
Checkmate but Jesus
right you take no risk ever of white
ever losing such a position I love it
can we switch to the game of elshon
versus yes because I know it's not very
influential towards the standings but it
was a very good exchange sacrifice yes I
think so too when we left it we left it
around these parts and we were
mentioning the really really good night
versus the really really good Bishop
and elshon came up with a very nice
concept he said you know what
your Bishop is so good okay I'm going to
eliminate it yes and by the way did we
see G5 we did see uh G5 played in the
Christopher you get Christopher putting
some pressure on you're rolling the
patties and I love this night it really
just reinforces the king and like the
the king is really safe
whenever you go H4 in HG this Knight
will block the f file the king will have
escape hatch and isn't it time to play
moves like uh I don't know uh C C5 Rook
C1 and can I make a passer and I wanted
to move to this game just because elshon
is down to his last four minutes oh
really yes uh still only five moves to
go so it's not panic mode yet Hans is
playing very quickly
our idea was a rook H6 later right yes I
mean after you've taken just Jacob yeah
we made Seven whoa whoa he's going
before the pawns whoa okay I'm upon
Grabber no he's going for the pause I
mean he's looking for membership in the
very very exclusive chess club
Pond grubbers are saying grubber's
Anonymous first you have to admit that
you have a problem if you're looking for
uh Rehabilitation for immediately Hans
played this movie
how many moves have have the only four
moves to go okay
okay so but there are some serious
pitfalls okay let's fall into them you
don't want to take on it on B7 that's no
B7 just to show just to show us very
nice yes sorry so if you do take on B7
if you get greedy right now I agree G3
you take on G3 back okay and now I have
E5 which finishes the game
E5 yes
it is you cannot take a person because
Queen is hanging so you have to take on
this Challenge and then it's a beam
unbelievable just a second I was taught
that past pawns can be worth a rook if
you're telling me that they're not your
passports are not going there
I mean I'm gonna but you're telling me
this I take on G3 you take on the street
with some ideas yeah I take on C5
oh nicer
so Queen takes B7 falling for that nasty
trick maybe he realizes and now he's
starting to panic because he was
planning on taking that oh he took him
wow oh he's in trouble
no because he's got the idea of hg3
Queen check on C8 first yes he's got the
idea then I check you again it's six
years old and then I recapture the pawn
and there's no E5
get back in time because with the queen
on C8 so I go King F7 right okay let's
let's you can get seven I take back the
pawn oh I go Rook H6 now I understand
that you want to Checkmate me that I got
it I have some Queen C2 coming yes
[Music]
no he was supposed to include yep E5 E5
oh he missed it oh my gosh and elshon
pause you you usually it's one of those
signs when they pick up the pen yes
they're ready to write down the move
then then you play a move that they
weren't ready to write down and that's
shocking
I think elshon went from a better
position to losing in like three moves
that's what I thought the sequence is so
important because he was going down to
his last five minutes and there is a lot
of options in the position right Queen
A7 was one way to go C5 was another way
to go rookie one was another way but he
chose the worst one yeah because of this
move E5
because of E5 oh my goodness so Queen A7
h4e took the pawn which was I think okay
but it was absolutely crucial that he
played Queen check in this position
maybe he's worse and so on he did not
and then it's this oops cold shower cold
shower as this a double attack in the
position the queen is under attack on B7
as is the Knight and Elsa yeah
the harsh oh yeah hold on one more look
help me out here guys okay you just
played E5 I'll trade you trade yes I'll
play C5 and now instead of can is it no
the pawns are way too slow
oh and Hans knows it as well he's got
this this is the move Rook F5 I if it's
my turn with C6 I might be able to turn
the tables it's white black to play
pardon me and Rook F5 is a clincher yeah
[Music]
he's been having a roughed organic
chemical somebody shows painful
variations oh yes oh yes this is really
wonderful you know it's really strange I
I talk to a lot of people who are not
chess players and I tell them such I
make a comment like chess is a cruel
game and they look at me with like no
understanding they say how can chess be
a cruel game say you're not a player
you're not a player because chess is a
cruel game just a few moments before
elshon had played a really wonderful
exchange sacrifice set up outplayed Hans
had a good position and in three moves
has lost the game the move E5 you you
saw it with this pen right I mean he was
ready to like make your move
um
you know and again it's so cruel because
exactly this moment mentally you're
thinking my knight is unassailable yeah
so he just resigns resignation wow yes
he doesn't just check the it's
unassailable anytime you play E5 I take
it on poisson so you can't touch my
knight so he's thinking I'm Rock Solid
I'm super safe I just went upon for free
what's the problem and then E5 it comes
with a double attack and elshon resigns
yes I'm probably not feeling very well
but Hans is probably thinking oh my
strategy of playing I'm trouble paid off
it it definitely paid off handsomely wow
yeah
handsomely
handsome I'm not sure what that means
he got the full point that's pretty bad
the point is a point that is it to me
yeah that's a handsome Point uh Sam
Savion Ray Robson and again that is
cruising right towards a draw
the ladies we haven't seen Jennifer you
we knew that Jennifer was in trouble was
in trouble but that was on move five how
how I think it was Musa actually uh what
happened after what's the trouble yes
okay so we got here and the troubles
began
so she belongs to this phone on C5 and
goes for the Knight on G4 the Knight
dropped back
Knight to F4 okay to the bishop he's
thinking if I can get my bishop and
maybe my queen to E4 There She Goes
Knight to D4 okay Trey trade Bishop E4
it's almost looking like she has a
position
and now it goes back
yes whoa now you cannot do cast linkage
Force hanging correct but what what to
do S3 okay go back with a knight if you
can yes I think
it's like she's clawing her way back
into the game I want to say maybe some
King F2 ideas just King F2 before Bishop
maybe B4 yeah
oh I definitely like you know B3 B4
Bishop B2 in order to get that guy
developed I don't know if it's possible
yeah because I
I still have to harmonize my position
and what about deal with my C7 phone
I'm just glad you asked glad you asked
yeah hello everybody everybody likes to
be a hero and Bishop even maybe a six to
make sure Rook doesn't come I don't know
I'm not sure yeah you the the the the
the bad news is that uh there's there's
uh active uh attacking possibilities for
a black on the king side but
who said the older I get the more I
value your bones
sounds like a very very very wise man
yeah through the magic of Television
there's this moment where your your
opponent picks up their piece it picks
up their pen and they're prepared to
write down your move and then the move
that you've played is such a shock that
you don't respond you don't just write
down the move you you take that pause
and that's the tell that's when you know
your opponent has missed the move you've
played E5 and he just resigned after
that because he was losing a piece and
oh what a terrible feeling Christian oh
absolutely it's it's devastating but
this is what happens when you're just
having a rough event uh these
tournaments are so difficult you're not
catching a break that's the problem
you're not playing an open Event you
lose a couple of games then you're going
to play a much lower rated opponent and
then you have the opportunity to bounce
back you're playing Killers every single
round right this is exactly what's
happening with and whenever these guys
smell weakness smell blood in the water
they're like sharks and you can see that
with Hans as well in today's game yeah
with two games in our history yes
exactly yeah so one draw quick pretty
quick draw between Lebanon and with
Wesley so and then we have one decided
game Hansen even just won against took
advantage of elshon's time
mismanagement I want to say but it
wasn't the position Alshon had chances
there I wanted to turn our attention to
Arena Crush room Rochelle Woo's game
when we left it we thought Arena had
pretty much blown it she stood worse she
agreed with us the move E6 is a kind of
her way of saying uh I just I I messed
up now at this moment Rochelle's doing
well but then Rachelle decides that
she's
starts or wants to trade everything with
the move Bishop E4 you kind of want to
leave some pieces on the board don't you
Rook E7 would likely have been my choice
just to bring the Rooks and pressure
upon she did it like this she does stand
better but we can imagine let's say I
make a move just any like say H4 we can
imagine that if we do get into such a
situation I have one weakness yes I've
got to properly defended and I don't
think Arena will fear such a double Rook
ending I think yes it's going to be
pretty Jewish exactly what about Anna
zatonski versus Alice Lee again this was
this Queens Gambit accepted well
somewhere somehow on a one to two
Bishops
um
slight Advantage for white nothing major
exactly at this moment a game we haven't
seen Tata versus Sophie what is going on
here
not sure but we have special guests yeah
we have one of those sharks as you said
one of the Sharks is with Christian
we are doing it have Hans Neiman with us
here in the studio after his victory
against eroshan us first of all
congratulations uh important victory for
you would you say that yeah very
important like today I realized I
decided you know either I'm going to
lose I'm going to win there's no there's
no in between and that's exactly what it
felt like from for us as well the
commentators you were putting a lot of
pressure on your opponent's time was
that the case was that the strategy
going into into the game
well um
I just didn't feel like thinking at all
and yeah I definitely wanted to put some
pressure and uh considering I think
whenever someone is having a difficult
tournament you have to
even he held himself very well under the
pressure but uh eventually he cracked
but uh okay I was not in the mood for
another Berlin game today let's just put
it that way it was definitely a very
tense middle game I have to say uh take
us through the yeah so let's first after
Knight D7 all the way he's curious
Bishop like Bishop B3 just stopped this
entire plan like if H6 Bishop H4 and G5
Bishop g395 is 95. oops yes okay Queen
A5 apparently there's Queen A5 yeah I
don't know okay but it's just funny that
there's actually okay it's still okay I
was let's say I'm not considering but
yeah this was the what I I mean yeah
okay and I just saw an ig5 and I stopped
yeah then to go beyond that but anyways
um yeah so now this is actually really
quite nice but again I played the king's
Indian and he goes Bishop G5 and he had
he played let's go before he I think
before he plays Bishop G5 on the the
third move
uh so here instead of C4 he's publishing
Bishop G5 before but that'll be honest I
did not
uh prepare uh I did not take the
preparation too seriously so maybe he's
also played this but I was hoping he
would go for something because if he can
if they play this against the king's
Indian no I played the keys in every
game if I can get this you know it's
like such a fight and and we were
discussing about that as the tournament
drags on uh the energy levels are much
more important rather than just prepare
for like five hours before the game yeah
to be honest um I do not uh even check a
single single variation in the king's
Indian
but um I had already decided that I was
just going to you know freestyle a bit
because um you know I felt like I need
to go back to my roots of playing just
absolutely psychotic uh chess
um because I I I I don't know what's
gotten into me you know playing the
Berlin and uh and trying to make draws
you know I've always you know I've
become a bit too professional
um but I felt like if any day was the
day to go absolutely insane
and disregard you know all the chess
principles then today was the day and it
paid off uh it did but let's yeah so so
of course when I get you know this the
first year so this is of course amazing
yes this is like a dream yeah and okay
he's and then A5 okay let's first A5
this is an inaccuracy because again
uh you're never going to okay in my
opinion if you're ever going to punish
my let's say specular display you have
to Castle Queen side like like if you're
going to if something's going to happen
it's going to happen to exploit the king
side weaknesses so A5 for me is just
weird because first of all okay after A5
you know the Rook is sort of stuck to
the pawn and also this beef the beef is
like the the beep break is coming so it
just didn't make much sense to me uh
okay you should note that B5 is sort of
a threat
um so like yeah it's sort of a threat
because
um I can't even think of like a passing
movie yeah Rook A3 is I guess stopping
it but what if you go Castle then you
don't have the Rook on the age Yeah Yeah
but I for example right now B5 would be
an idea because if you know take P3
that's like the worst movie I could
think of but but basically the point is
that after a b a b your forces are going
to eight and then you the d8 D5 Pawn
fall so B5 is sort of a threat so I can
understand why you play A5 but just from
a positional perspective I was like okay
it's just game over like like in this
position I'm thinking okay like
life is good I'm gonna Cruise you know
and I was cruising let's go to the next
critical Moment Like sure I was so happy
Knight G4 you know F5 you know 95 to you
know and then and then Queen E5 was so
happy with this tick tick you know pitch
five Bishop G6 you hear us okay game is
over I I was like this is just lost and
I okay of course it's extremists back
and live and I see it's equal but I'm
just thinking like you know I've got the
B6 break coming I've got Bishop on D4
I've got G4 H5
of course by optimism uh is a bit uh
unfounded as usual but I just disagree
with the computer here to be honest I I
complete this okay so yeah so Rick have
seven more practical perspectives yeah
yeah I look at this position I'm like I
don't believe it's equal but let's go
back so I thought maybe what if I play
Rook of Queen egyptica five
uh this was maybe uh and here's where G4
okay so uh okay uh because when I was
playing Rook F7 and then he plays at 94
it's like oh wait Knight X5 is right
um but okay Bishop D4 yeah Rook E3 okay
so everything like yeah so okay G4 Rook
G3 yeah so okay yeah this is just
ridiculous why not just the B5 like this
whole Rook F4 because I thought like I
just miscalculated like when I play Rook
F5 okay because here okay let's say just
not rectify like you just look at the
structure yes like I've got this is just
a dream like come on this is just game
over like like let's say you play B5
yeah let's say I play B5 a b takes and
you go like Rook G2 like come on this is
just disgusting like uh this whole
structure you've got pressure everywhere
H5 I I should just I should have I just
had zero patience
um and this is very stupid you know I
again this is just a disgusting position
but I play Rook of five just a way too
uh way too arrogant and uh completely
underestimate this and then now I'm like
sitting here and I'm like wait you know
this is uh this is not too pretty yeah
yeah so I guess Rick F5 is just uh
completely just yeah I missed I just
missed everything yeah I thought you
know he's going low on time just going
to collapse you know uh game over and
then he does this and I'm like uh yeah
okay that is bursting my birthday this
position yeah oh Queen D1 okay that's
ridiculous
yeah so here again to A7 did you
calculate this whole H4 E5 at the end of
it well I was like or was that
I was more looking at his clock and uh
trying to play the move H4 at all costs
you know because
what else am I going to do in this
position am I going to sit there and
like pretend like I'm okay or like I
understood that the only way that I do
not like lose is to play H4 so if it's
not like let's just say that um I I had
I was taking a very psychological
approach here and then when he played
Queen A7 I'm like okay you know it's I I
already knew he was going to lose like I
could already when I was 27 I know the
game was over because because it's like
the you know this you know if you look
at the momentum had completely shifted
right like you know in the opening I do
this weird stuff I play quickly I take
control and then I have all the moments
and then I make one just idiotic move
and he plays like three genius moves and
I'm sitting there like an idiot and then
uh here okay he plays a queen Ace uh
yeah Queen takes B7 yeah and I'm yeah
okay so he still could have had Queen
theater I saw this um
but but
yeah okay I also considered um instead
of this I could go Rook f8 yeah Queen E6
Queen F7 yeah but here he I yeah now he
can take I thought if he can take first
and then King takes after it's still not
easy um
yeah it's probably fine but like Rook C1
Rook C5 I wasn't sure how to evaluate
this but the considering my previous
position I was you were happy I was very
happy I was very happy um uh but then
like yeah okay this E5 Ampersand is like
it's just it's a very interesting
concept because uh like this you never
think this Pawn is going to move but the
queen is sort of uh it's a very nice
concept probably the only way I could
have won this but I guess you know when
you're an arrogant idiot you get
rewarded sometimes
um uh to all the people who think I'm a
humble I am a complete idiot and uh I
have a lot to learn in chess and uh I
have too many things to work on uh and
I'm yeah what are you going to work
during the rest day
no more berlins
that's not even about working on the
Russia it's just it's going to the rest
day and somehow
um convincing myself not to just finish
the next game with an hour and a half
you know it's like uh no no I just rest
day you know
try to go to the pool like at a time
we'll know what we'll expect
um
Paparazzi yes you're expecting that or I
have a question what was that well I I
haven't been going to the pool much
after that I don't really I don't really
uh enjoy that but no no okay it's the
rest day and uh I think I think a
comeback is brewing because now I have
two more whites and I'm playing uh
Linderman and Liang to the lower seeds
so I could feel a a comeback uh I think
I think a comeback is certainly coming
and uh I've definitely been humbled a
lot in these past in this tournament so
I think it's always good when someone is
arrogant as me is humbled
guys
here yeah I have a question to Hans uh
how does it feel to be a professional
chess player these days I ask also this
question Jeffrey but I wonder would you
recommend to the others to become
professional chess players these days
well um uh you think I'm a professional
chess player I don't know I'm asking you
and if you consider yourself I think as
a professional well you know
I think
advice how to become a professional
chess player or how to survive
disadvantages you know it's sucking your
soul mm-hmm
sorry I didn't hear you yeah I mean what
are advantages and disadvantages you
live this life of professional players
say that the life is not it's definitely
not for everyone and I think a lot of
people you know end up
I think it's it's an extremely difficult
life
um unless you make it so I think it's
it's very similar to sort of
um some music or or something you know
where you really really have to
um have a very very um High pain and and
stress tolerance and you have to be able
to have this ultimate confidence in
yourself uh that no matter what you will
achieve for example right now you know
it would be very easy for me to be very
discouraged by my career
um and by what is happening but I I sort
of have this and I've always had this
um faith and confidence in myself which
has allowed me to to persevere uh
through very difficult moments in my
chest career because to be honest there
were like probably four different
Junctions where I could have quit chess
forever so
um thankfully I I made it I made it
through those but I I think that's a
perfect dress player
you know I wouldn't recommend it to
everyone unless you're you know unless
you
really really believe in yourself or you
have the proper support
um you know if you've got uh
certain countries like Switzerland you
know giving you a kilo of gold when you
become a grand master and maybe it's
okay maybe but uh
it's not something for the lighthearted
I'll say that yeah and you see a lot of
people struggle to break through and
then go and do you know stuff like uh
commentating and podcasting
you know for the people who just can't
uh don't have the mental strength to
actually win the trust so you know I
feel attacked
that's okay it just isn't for everyone
and you know
um you were a streamer yourself come on
were or are you are I I'm gonna lie I
cannot tell you last time I streamed I
definitely wouldn't say I am a streamer
yeah that I'm a competitive chess player
on the path to becoming world champion
that's how I would put my LinkedIn
profile Hans this is your first U.S
Championship you've got 10 Rounds under
your belt what uh have you learned thus
far I've learned a lot this has actually
been a very introspective time in my
life okay and
um I learned a lot and I think that um
I'm really looking forward to
um to working on my game and and taking
all of the lessons that I've learned on
and off uh the the chessboard because
this has been uh
um a very unique time and uh I think the
tournament um
um
of course it hasn't gone well but you
know when you're losing games there's
always a lot to learn from them
um so in a specific regard I would say
that the
I would not like to share what
weaknesses I've discovered in my own
game but uh I'm really looking forward
to to just improving and continuing
my journey as a chess player well good
luck on your journey and good luck in
the last three rounds enjoy your free
day Hans thank you absolutely turning
our attention to Jennifer oops by the
way we do have a repetition going on in
the game between Christopher
oh it's uh yes oh well okay it's going
to be a stalemate uh shortly and or uh
naked Kings A5 and A6
but look at Christopher he makes this A5
exactly with a certain power that's how
he played g3 at the time earlier just as
like yes the blueprint he wants to show
the success I'm the one who has an extra
phone in this position and look at him
go
that's interesting is the second game in
a row in which Fabiano finishes in this
particular Sterling it's still late
fist bumps handshake What's it gonna be
nah let's go with the handshake on this
one as uh well it's it wasn't a bullet
but Fabi had to do some dodging in this
game Christian oh absolutely yeah yeah I
think Fabiano was under some pretty
serious pressure and we could see that
from his uh time management right where
you spend 40 minutes in a seemingly well
it's not even a new position right
because it's a theoretically known and
sound position but when you spend four
minutes for one move you understand that
uh you don't like the position right
the trend of this game you're going to
be under pressure for the remainder of
the game and you don't actually have a
lot of chances to win that and this is
exactly what he did but then again he's
a prophet National player he knows that
he sees the fact that Ray Robson is also
not putting any pressure with black PCS
on the defensive end and he understands
look with a draw he keeps and one round
closer to winning the championship I'm
still in the leadership position
absolutely and here are our results
three results three results
between 11 around and Restless so and
push the for you and Fabiano caruana and
we have one decisive result Hans Neiman
defeated celson
it looks like another result is a upon
us as we're expecting a wonder and
linear to make a claim of a draw looking
for an Arbiter where's an Arbiter visit
too many kids
ministry of them at the same time a lot
of
repetitions uh need to be confirmed
since today linear is not against the
draw right yesterday you remember there
was a claim come on Frank
move it he's setting up for the next
round and he's not he's not worried
about this yeah here we go here we go uh
by the way I understand the way it
actually is going on Leonard Otis he's
got all of the games monitoring on
leeches and the leeches confirms there's
a three move repetition coming up and
Leonard is saying to the Arbiters it's
correct and then the Arbiters knew that
it's not because we had an incorrect
claim yes the other day as well we've
got the two-minute penalty and they do
it rather instantly in the past they
used to go to another board yes the very
first moves they would check the whole
game and there's uh our photographer
extraordinaire Leonard uh behind his
monitor right there Leonard Otis uh I
wanted to turn our attention to the game
of Jennifer you because uh after all she
came into today's round in clear first
she made things very very very difficult
on herself and in the last few moves uh
still strange things are going on
um I I can only guess that she did not
want to see F5 and F4 and the night
coming to
at five so she herself played the move
F4 and in truth I would have really
resisted playing this move because I
hate giving my opponent you know a
objectively such a an outpost
um I think played it very well she moved
her Queen over and I'm expecting Queen
G6 is which we've got and okay it's
crazy because there's so many strange
imbalances going on in the position
first of all White's upon up yes uh
second of all white has terrible
development uh with for the pieces
they're they're completely kind of a
mismatch of things as Bishop on A6 makes
a very strange impression of the night
on D3 makes a strange impression et
cetera Etc and for the moment Queen
takes G2 is a big threat when you've
played the move H to H4 sort of like
you're kind of resisting playing the
move castles which just got played and
again I can imagine
um Naji playing the move Queen G3 if she
could get in the move Knight G4 we all
know what happens next yes
Knight F2 to protect this G4 Square
because G3 probably won't follow yes
this is Jennifer when she's in a good
position imagine when she's not in a
good position okay Queen G3 I will play
Rook F3 and uh I'll I'll give back the
pawn and I'll kick your queen as far
away even at the cost of the pawn yes
I'm happy to get in those moves keep in
mind Bishop takes D4 is what's on and
again we do have Queen G3 uh Bishop
takes D4 D4 is on Jennifer's agenda and
I'm gonna ask uh Christian what the
evaluation of this
mismatch is in the ladies game because I
don't know what's going on well it's a
very strange move that she just played
and actually she's doing some moves
flowing on the board right now Queen G3
Rook to F3 okay we expect Queen takes
actually I think we have Queen takes H4
on the board okay The Rook is ready to
protect the king side so whenever I go
Knight G4 I go Rook H3 I'm fine exactly
what do you do if I go A4
A4 yes I'm not sure what's happening
that that that's a that I think is uh
our broadcast is a resetting yeah
resetting the moment yes okay you go A4
this idea to move this bishop yes from
this diagonal so that you could play
Bishop takes D4 or queen takes D4 or
queen takes Queen takes D4 also Knight
to C5 is coming as well
really nasty threats right makes a great
deal of sense if Black's threats on the
king side are held at Bay 84 A5
I'm going to tell you the assessment and
you probably will be shocked okay right
now is plus six for white
I'm not sure why our thing keeps on uh
resetting itself it's a big it's a bit
disconcerting apologies for that but
plus six plus six thanks to the movie A4
yes prior to the move A4 it's what no no
I mean if you don't play after the move
Queen to G3 Queen to G3 is a huge blocks
yes because of this idea of Rook F3 and
A4 I don't have time what what was the
better move except the better move I
mean to be honest the trend was already
reversing right yeah
Jennifer was completely down it was a
minus four at one wow for a Nazi uh and
the best move by the way is Rook to C8
which is not to give up the exchange
just to give up the exchange and try to
free up uh some space for your pieces on
the queen side it's not looking like a
natural move right Queen G3 definitely
makes a lot of sense from a visual
perspective but once you understand that
okay they spawn on H4 you can take it
you want it it doesn't help your
position at all and in the meantime I'm
just completely demolishing you on the
coincide and you're not in time to
create any counter play once you
understand that you understand why this
position is so bad for uh black wow
Jennifer is repeating wait wait wait a
minute what what are we what do you mean
she took on D4
she's not repeating we we got the wrong
information
um
Irina is repeating right now let's take
a look so Rook to f8 King to G3 Rook to
E8 King to F2 let's take and I think
with a slight slightly worse Arena was
slightly worse and she bailed out into
this ending we have a draw in and a
triathlon yes I think she should be of
course she's not happy with this result
but considering the fact which position
she got she was maybe maybe it's not so
bad after unfortunately yeah yeah
because she she missed that opportunity
and okay where was the repetition oh yes
it was just Rook to fa King to G3 and
wrote back King back and this is how
they repeated and made a draw again back
to the
um uh Jennifer uh game because Again
Jennifer entered today's today's round
with a half a point lead over her
nearest Rivals Megan and Irina yes
should Jennifer win she will increase
herina just made a draw she's looking
like she's gold up until the moment she
played Bishop takes D4 maybe this move
was actually a big Miss because this
bishop suddenly is about to get active
the move A4 I like it very much very
very much suddenly it becomes so visual
once you see that you're going to go A5
take this pawn and keep blacks pieces at
Bay she took took Bishop Rook I think
we're up to date I guess I could expect
Queen G4 for example Queen G4 and
threatening Checkmate there's nothing
about those meat and one threats yes
[Music]
um okay so if I'm in White Shoes my
dream position is to go night
C5 and Bishop E2 and just kicked Black's
pieces as far away
Bishop E2 and Bishop H5
trapping the queen yes oh very nice very
nice uh okay is there something that uh
Naji could do right here right now that
would disturb those plans
I'm sure I don't see it either I mean
well those types of moves I I start to
look for the shock value of such moves
you know uh but uh it's shocking about
his chocolate it's shockingly bad right
oh by the ooh ooh oh shockingly bad yes
we are trying kind of to do something
yes because you're completely desperate
the sad aspect of this type of
Physicians you actually don't have
anything to do maybe maybe my queen on
G4 is actually just terrible uh if I if
I drop back with my queen with the
intention of night and Rook uh Am I
Dreaming are you and what is your night
doing on G4 I don't know Knight C5 I
continue with my plan yeah yep and now
we're the queen on E7 I'm even thinking
of transitions uh okay that's probably
an important move I didn't want to see
Queen 26th
yeah exactly and now Our Queen to let's
say
C3 I don't want to get hit by okay and
yay At Last I I met on H6 it was was
terrible yeah yeah
I need to find some ideas okay so I
cannot move the Rook on H3 because you
go
Queen to H4 so that's problematic
yeah I don't want to see that on the
board
[Music]
I know of course I have F2 but I'm just
saying that uh don't go there so I
probably want to go Bishop to C4 right
Bishop D5 Bishop D5 kind of forced and
how do we assess this position I like
white I mean I think white is for choice
but uh and what has by the way she did
play Queen G4 putting the queen maybe on
the
least desirable Square Black's pieces
are fighting over uh that square Queen
came back to F2 nope that's not the oh
let me just refresh where am I yeah and
we discussed that Knight C5 Bishop B2 or
Bishop F1 are the moves which can follow
yes exactly
and I like that Knight C5 move
very much who she played Rook C1 okay
that's any time you can develop with the
tempo you know I'm signing up I love
that's I I dream of developing Italian
but I have to go to the game between
Megan and Talia because again Megan she
came into today's round she's a half a
point tied with arena for second place
and she's a pawn down
uh one two three four and three islands
two islands we have to be suffering yes
you have to speak a Common Language uh
looks like by the way it didn't tell
doesn't that mean that Talia comes into
today's place she will actually get one
one point and she will be you will have
six points right but she came in on a
streak right two games in a row she won
already so now Patrick if yes exactly
wow
once she wins this game she's fighting
for the top places in this tournament
and what a comeback yeah she started
incredibly so very frustrated with her
start with Talia but then as you say
putting together a win streak will
change your outlook uh I'm looking at
this pawn and I'm saying yeah I'd like
to go for it I'm looking this bishop and
I'm saying yeah I would like to put the
bishop on D4 put my Bishop on G2 keep
that beep on the only passer in the
position for white as the beep on keep
that beep on well contained
even maybe tucking my king on the B6
square and hoping that these Pawns in
the center on the king side looks
winning to my eyes a huge result and
again because Arena Drew
Jennifer is guaranteed most probably
will win this game yes
and here's the ladies
she still is on the second and actually
she caught Jennifer but Jennifer will
win most probably exactly yeah
that was the early one but then we had a
whole slew of draws right three draws
yes between sam7 Ray Robinson Wonderland
New York Dominguez Christopher you and
Fabiano caruana and we have only one
besides a game
just oh oh oh oh painful to watch that
was a train wreck uh you know taking
place under our eyes even Hans uh saw it
from afar that he had this movie E5 yes
and played for it played on the clock
and poof uh well got rewarded what can I
say but this is huge for the ladies
Talia wins
um
Arena draws that's good for Jennifer yes
I
mean it's good for Jennifer please
Anastasia I got yes now we have this
different evaluation system exactly yeah
especially at the end of the tournament
it really helps to understand yes what's
going on who has the advantage yes is it
right I just have feeling that still
maybe we will sit at the two Bishops
given Checkmate to the king like for
example if I was in Megan's place I will
try to sacrifice my Bishop for a couple
of pounds if possible or something like
this in order to kind of maybe have some
Jewish chances and two Bishops Checkmate
is pretty easy to give it's not nothing
I was very very proud of myself as a
youngster when I learned
these basic mates the two Bishops I
thought was so easy I just like patted
myself on the back whereas I struggled
with the bishop at night I think
everybody has decisions like you
remember everything is fine like right
everything is absolutely clear for you
then you need to play a game and imagine
let's say your king or a king of your
opponent is not on the last train
yes and then you kind of try to find a
way right menu today I I'm I'm wondering
at myself why I found it so difficult
because okay I'm a grand master and I've
got it down to just that I could do it
in 60 seconds I can do it in 15 seconds
like Dania noraditski can right I can't
do it in 15 but I can do it in 60. uh
but then I'm I'm trying to remember why
I had it so difficult right why it was
so difficult but I think a lot of top
Grand Masters are like they forget how
difficult chess is and this bishop and
Knight you know they if you if you
haven't worked it out and mastered it
you can really trick yourself at the
board you start seeing the wrong ideas
it's terrible yes it is and today you
can have all this you can use all this
Workshop
um
these applications that test your
knowledge in those particular endings
that we're mentioning bishop and Knight
friends you can play it 100 times and so
great yeah you're fine how's our 13 year
old Alice Lee doing because again just
as as the leaders are stumbling maybe
that will open up the door for Alice uh
she has
defending the black pieces against Anna
zatonski Anna just captured upon on six
and is looking to play the move a384
she's got the two Bishops that's white
but well
um
I don't know uh I'm feeling much more
drawish than anybody has any it
definitely feels very drama very strong
unfortunately
but again you know Alice what she did
yesterday and I mean I really mean this
very very sincerely it's fantastic to
see the youthful the young players
I don't want no stinking draw I'm going
to play and play and play and play an
arena because believe it where's the
respect where's the respect every time
U.S Champion right
you could really make a drawing right
exactly no she will play until then and
to play for the four pawns versus The
Rook that just that was the tip of the
Hat a draw going on here Sabina versus
rouyang
um well uh Rue Yang has got an exchange
should be winning for black Megan we
think is much worse probably losing and
it's all about Jennifer now let's see
let's see what the his time travel
Factor it is in this case yes yes so two
minutes and 48 seconds only for uh
Johnny for you and still seven moves to
go okay and the valuation oh she's she's
doing well she's better for sure now how
much better it's it's a practicality
question not plus six anymore right no
no no by any means no no it's it's only
plus two okay only plus two yes but from
a practical perspective I still have my
ideas I still have my shots in that I
can potentially get as black okay I see
that white would love to get rid of this
Knight something like Knight C5 Bishop
E2 and maybe on a good day include The
Rook what is Black's what are black
shots uh Christian perhaps I can try to
get on the D file fast okay so that
whenever you go Knight C5 maybe I have
some ideas I'm not sure if with that
Rook or with a B Rook okay because while
I'm saying that uh is because if you go
with the B Rook I still have this move
Rook to F7 in my back pocket right
that's going to the seven uh defend the
seventh Rank and I think that's
definitely an improvement okay in uh
Black's position perhaps after Knight to
C5 let's try Rook F7 okay and uh I'll uh
we comply yeah
and I again I'm just thinking anything
close to my king I wanted
whoa whoa whoa I suddenly I I spot a
pussycat there look at this a putty tat
I got a double attack your favorite your
favorite tactics everything yes where's
the double attack I'm attacking The Rook
oh that position no I thought you he
meant after this move Queen to E8 played
by uh oh sorry no Naji okay sorry we
were we're on the wrong position we were
on an analysis position and it was there
was a queen H4 Let me refresh my board
but I just opened up the discussion and
open up the opportunity for Jennifer to
play Knight F2 which she did she seized
it right away she played Knight F2
saying the Knight is stuck oh excuse me
the Knight is stuck I want to play
Knight takes G4 don't you you cannot
think
of Knight takes F2 that's mating one
perhaps this helped Jennifer's case for
a big advantage in the position I think
Queen 28 was a bit too passive for uh
Naji okay see so you were advocating
all right Knight F2 H5 I mean I don't
see the other move
I'm gonna do a slow horrible I cannot
believe it right I was thinking yeah
Queen H4 to tickled upon on H
five but also again I'm anything that
you know kind of chases the attackers
away while opening up so this is the
only thing that I'm seeing as an idea
for black yes since she played a move
Queen to E8 Queen to A4
uh-huh can we go from behind Queen A4
and queen D1 if you allow me to yeah
funny uh I remember a game I was playing
against Gary Kasparov was on the black
side of a king's Indian he had a queen
he went from like age five to D1 to A4
it was it was a billiard shot and then
was like whoa uh it's really shocking
when you you know you get these long
moves and they're unexpected the problem
is I have a I have a safety Square yeah
right yeah exactly which is kind of
unpleasant so Bishop is hanging but
probably don't even care oh no no no I'm
ready
so you have to give me a check and pawn
takes probably but now Bishop D3
you cannot take my Rook yeah The Rook is
The Rook is uh this one is not looking
yeah it's not maybe even maybe I know
Rook H7 maybe it's too much
immediately yeah that's an idea it's
possible but we don't need really like
queen d8 queen queen to d8 okay okay
that tickles The Rook so after Knight F2
Queen to D oh that's nice it's just an
idea
yeah Queen B6 uh is she gonna take the
Knight on G4
the next five moves so that's why she
plays fast and tries to keep everything
under control by the way that that move
Queen C3 that it does in a sense keep
everything under control right which
tells you could you play something like
more Brave like 96 Rook G7 I don't know
what what do you want me to do foreign
pertinent questions you have to play
most probably well then I then I give
back the exchange and you went upon in
the whole deal as well good for you I
would say so why didn't she do that uh
Queen went back to E8
Knight to F2 yes Queen
to d8
and once again we'll just take a look oh
I'm sorry yes and now Rook G7
and maybe it's not enough yes why not
and then because I think that I don't
have enough pieces to give a check
method
I said like Bishop D3 but now Rook F5
Oracle of seven yes it's like a rugby
sound yeah I don't have enough pieces
you ran out of firewood yes only maybe
Perpetual sometimes if if there is any
maybe not anyway
most likely going to see uh results
uh sorry where Ray Robson Jeffrey versus
sap oh okay I'm going to uh and we don't
have to jump therefore too long because
still the action is in this one
but they said again looks like it's
going to four verses that'll be a four
versus three that both of these players
know quite exactly
and
our apologies to both uh Alex Slenderman
and darussia doubtlessly played a a
tough fighting game but it was just that
the other games had attracted our
attention as I'm looking at this
position I'm seeing a fortress kind of
thing even though I like whites obvious
space Advantage anytime F5 comes uh
black will be very happy to trade
everything off the board and make a very
comfortable draw back to the game of
Jennifer because again uh time travel as
well as position dictates that we should
keep our eyes focused here after this
move Queen C3 I like what Jennifer is
doing yes keeping control but also I
like what Naji just did
Rook F7 and it's all about the control
over the C file and the control over
this A5 d8 diagonal because my queen
wants to land on P6 with a check exactly
or a potential pin right so I like this
move Rook to F7 but she's ready even to
give up this H7 Pawn oh absolutely
that's cool especially yes like
you don't see it everything oops excuse
me that was just a mouse slip so what we
were talking about is this uh
diagonal G1
and uh you're pitting the night but you
also you're hitting the bishop so I'm
thinking Rook C5 I mean I will I will I
see this as a defensive Rook I see this
is an aggressive rook and I'm thinking
Rook C5 is a nice way of just keeping
that Queen at Bay she's reaching for the
Rook she took it
harassing that's a surprise move for me
that is the big question how are you
going to continue after King takes F7
C5 Queen to C5 try to cover that B6
Square okay I def I I definitely am
eyeballing the pawn yes but I'm much
more concerned that the queen is more
dispensive wood than aggressive right
yeah that's what I feel how is the end
game after let's say queen B6 I'll take
it takes B6 even though maybe I should
take with the a pawn no no no I want to
go to C6 I want to invade via the C file
I do have
um Rook C3 is a way of keeping you once
again at Bay and that's actually going
to be just up actually an extra Pawn but
what if I go A5 now
there's five P5
um B5 yeah that's uh that's an
unfortunate sighting an unfortunate site
but I mean okay
it transfers the game into the engine
and then the whole point again is that
uh every time black tries to get some
activity for her pieces I'm I'm just in
time to uh
I was about to say Rook takes F7 and
then she stopped She taught for it
for no reason maybe six I don't know why
she was no Queen the sixth maybe was but
yeah okay Queen to B6 yeah that makes
sense yes maybe she was thinking about
this mobile but neighbor just
so just at this moment we were a little
bit confused why uh now she didn't
immediately recapture and queen B6 is a
legit move yes yes it was a it was a
something for her to consider and again
I'm thinking that this bishop is more of
a tactical Target
it's the next four moves that are going
to do one minute how many seconds yes of
this game
because if she manages Jennifer you that
is to exit the time travel situation
with a clear Advantage she will be in
Pole Position no question but only one
minute right now with a very complicated
position but Queen C5 is not one of
those moves that's complicated it's just
it's just such a an attractive looking
movie so what if I try to go a rook to
be six yeah with the idea of Rook C6 as
well yes yes so like would you like to
play no she went for D4 whoa D4 really
interesting War
we're stuck for a moment just because
like you consider this move at all like
I have to recalibrate you know like what
just happened uh perhaps I'm not a
friend I'm not a fan of this move I'm
seeing Rook B6 Rook C6 yes as you've
just prescribed and you have to go B5
and lock the bishop on A6 like that
that's not desire and she played it very
quickly Rook is six years so B5 what
else you can do things are getting
interesting guys
ah Jennifer
I tell you between her and Lanier I'm
not sure who's a bigger thrill seeker I
mean Jennifer likes to get into time
trouble uh almost as much as Lanier it's
like she needs that motivation I don't
know what it is but she needs that ever
extra kick to get her to play quicker
Rook B6 with the idea of Rook C6 and
queen C7 invade down the C file and
that's why we're thinking that this
invasion is too strong and we have to
stop The Rook from going to C6 as well
as capturing our Bishop we've got 37-7
37 seconds to do it
oh my goodness she's reaching for her
Bishop oh no she's going to come after
that that Rook invading is no you gotta
play B5 come on yes oh and Jennifer's 17
seconds 10 seconds oh God what is she
going to do
wow guys okay
yeah and we know Rook C6 should come
yeah
or what what else do you want yeah
one idea right Rook C6 looks absolutely
you have to force you have to play you
have to take over the open file that way
Naji is playing very well and very
efficiently in a time travel scramble
she knows her chances like Hans know
knew his chances with elshon
were at that moment yes right absolutely
Queen d2. yes what move are they on I'm
sorry 39. 39 was this last move okay
well that's good so she she's about to
make the time control I'm assuming
Knight takes F to Queen takes F2 Queen
C7
wow and then also my eyes Queen C7 makes
the most sense immediately we need to be
wise maybe just to keep the tension but
then what what happens if you take on G4
thank you that's a good question but
then Pawn text you cannot take with the
bishop yes or maybe you can and Bishop
D1 or okay
yes that's a trick I know I know I know
I agree with fire yeah in that situation
yeah
um some G3 ideas
oh
Queen C3 I was dreaming I I'm I I'm now
I'm getting worried that I got a bail
I'm not sure about Bailey I'm not sure
I'm bailing into a draw either uh ooh
boy oh boy Queen C8 Queen by the way
guys Quincy it was the best move in the
position really what is the difference
a light square a dark Square what else
would you like to know
remember when this king is yeah
the light squares of the dark squares
it's not for Quincy six and Nasi has an
advantage
what is
in a better position wow night Bishops
Bishop takes G4 that's a different uh
approach by Jennifer that's surprising
okay we're expecting after hd40 well
unfortunately Rook C2 has to be
considered right
but maybe I can start with uh Bishop A5
ah you are absolutely right Bishop H5
check would disturb so there's no choice
okay F takes G is a box so what if I
take on G4 first of all well there is G2
is an issue right yes
makes a very nice geomet pleasing unless
I again I have some wonderful bailouts
with them
checks or something no yes you cannot do
it so then you have to play what Rook G3
or Rook H7 yeah and three but then I go
H5 I can I mean I'm I mean a much better
position right now and if you take on H7
now G3 comes with Tempo oh yes yes yes
yes yes so it's even worse than taking
with the Knight first and then with the
bishop no that decision to retreat her
bishop and not to play B5 meant that she
lost complete control over the C file
and we're seeing uh that that the worm
has turned completely once again uh
black that is to say Naji is now in the
driver's seat she's the one
the bishop on on I mean look at this
bishop on D5 isn't that not lordly the
Rook comes to C2 and the idea of G3 just
plays itself uh how bad is it the
evaluation has definitely better black
but how bad decisive oh the size of this
decisive can you imagine how many times
this game had different evaluation right
the advantage just keeps flip-flops like
you you gave us plus six a moment ago
yes yes and now what is it when you say
decisive for black it's close to minus
two okay yeah it's pretty decent
Advantage so minus 1.6 with best play
um and it's not very clear why you would
do what the engine is recommending and
that is G3 Rook G3 and after H5 to try
to go for F5
and queen to G5 and get your own counter
chances by the way it is funny now that
the queen is on C8 and that's probably
one that's probably why she played it
she's anticipating F5 and then after e
takes F5 and Jennifer is looking at the
the shreds of her position she's
wondering where did all my advantage go
and I think it was it was this time
travel we're seeing time travel our
friend Maurice Ashley has this great
expression he says time trouble makes
fools of us all and it was in time
trouble that Jennifer played the move
Bishop E2 lost control over the C file
The Rook is where Bata sees about to
land she had to play the move B5 just
full stop so that the Rook could not go
to C6 The Rook could not go to C8 yes
she's entombing her Bishop but that's
just the way she had to play her
decision to play Bishop E2 meant that
oops this did not happen I am going to
have to refresh my board I apologies for
that uh
um
her decision to play Bishop E2 meant
that suddenly
Quincy
C2 and or C1 and blacks attack was uh
wonderful and we have caught up with the
players Bishop takes G for f takes G4
again Knight takes G forward the
desirable Knight G4
Rook C2
um that's it
time trouble Anastasia time travel I
know how many positions also I spoiled
in time travel I can't imagine I can how
does it feel
and she is shaking her head as she could
be seeing the U.S Championship ladies
Crown slip from her grass and uh
Christian your student uh beg him we
liked what she had been doing earlier do
we like her position now yes we do yes
uh beg him is right now in pole position
to uh take this one home especially
after this last move Knight to E4 it
seems her Advantage is increasing and if
we do see the very natural move Rook to
F1 and why am I saying natural because
these are the last few moves for why
check this out Knight Rook to D1 Rook to
D3 Rook to D1 Knight to C3 Knight back
to D5 Rook to D3 Rook to D1 so white is
just waiting right white is just waiting
for black to do something black is
hinting that maybe I want to transfer my
king uh to E8 and D7 and protect this
Pawn on a D6 but now after the last move
Knight to E4 you cannot go back you
cannot repeat this same situation
because now I go with the other Knight
to D2 once you move the rookie and the
F2 uh Pawn is hanging you cannot do that
so how do you defend right now the best
move in the position is something which
looks whoa wait Knight to F5 so you
could play Rook takes F3 but now I can
just simply go back right and now you're
actually just losing an exchange so I
don't see that as a highly likely
outcome come on the board Knight to C7
is another move as well
of course I'm not going to take because
then you take on F3 but what if I just
simply go back to E7 now you go back to
D5 let's say and now I go to E5 once
again it's all about vf2 Pawn if I
manage to get to F2 then you're in
trouble right you cannot take you're not
in time because I think you're getting
checkmated that's one check and I'm not
going to take but I'm going to go Knight
F3 one mate Knight takes G3 two mates
Rook to H through you cannot defend uh
both of them
interesting situation right now ashrita
38 minutes uh she has been playing very
quickly we've passed the time control so
the ladies have plenty of time to think
about uh the position but it does seem
like uh beg him is putting some pressure
right now on her opponent and she has
some decent chances to win this one that
looks like some Dutch painting you know
Old Masters Sunday going across uh
begum's face
well after the time trouble Anastasia
what do you say a break time huh yes
let's have a tea time tea
time uh we'll see you all on the on the
other side of the brain
[Music]
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spassky match examining their early
lives and careers leading up to their
classic match you can join John live on
October 18th at the World Chess Hall of
Fame or watch the live stream on the
World Chess Hall of Fame YouTube channel
that's October 18th John Donaldson live
more information at St louisjessclub.org
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
and welcome back to round 10 of us chess
championships and we have only one
result in the women's section only Irina
Crush made the draw with Rochelle Wu wow
six six fighting games though in the way
but in the open section in the office
certainly different situation right six
out of seven games of sorry yes um
games are over because Alex Slenderman
has also made a draw yes unbelievable so
uh only one game remains in the opening
open section pardon me Jeffrey Jean
versus m
and we think that one is going to well
in fact they're repeating uh at this
moment so we do expect that game also to
be a draw so only one decisive game in
the open again Hans Neiman taking
advantage of alshon's time trouble to
secure as he said a much needed win he
wasn't happy with his results I'm
looking at the game between Tata and
Sophie if that pawn were on H6 I mean it
would be so easy we'd go King F3 we've
got checkmating patterns uh very unusual
that
um in a major piece ending a rook ending
that that white has this mating pattern
but thanks to the four Rooks on the
board tatev still has
real winning chances yes I want to say
King can go through King G8 so you kind
of have to be able to
defend your king
the simplest way of putting it but we're
looking at a number of draws but also
maybe a number of wins as well Anna
zatonski is I think about to draw should
she play Bishop takes E7 against Alice
Lee for a long time I thought Rue Yang
Yin was winning against uh Sabina but
now with the queen yeah it should still
be winning I was thinking that there was
a bishop C4 check ideas but Megan Lee
and Talia yes
um
I don't know I I was surprised that
Talia made the decision to trade the
light squared Bishops like right here if
I'm in telia shoes I'm thinking this
bishop is trapped yes simply in tuned
nothing to be done and I would be
thinking of Moves Like Bishop F3 and
slowly
get an outside h-pond passer with Bishop
she went for uh the trade of Bishops and
um
more work yes maybe more work more work
ahead of her in this game Jennifer you
the huge game
I was about to say some something about
the Arbiters are going to have to do
something about that glare because I
would find that just simply too uh
distracting oh excuse me
just pick up the pawn so that's it that
wins the game yes oh I apologize uh to
tell you I just simply
Bishop's seven yes it's a wonderful move
guys guys please I didn't think we're
going to end up in that situation but
look at what's happening in the backing
game she did win in exchange okay
test I'm going to quiz you guys okay the
best move what what sorry I'm thinking
about Knight F2 Knight F2 yes yes that
is the move yes look at that beautiful
move nice yes
I'm telling you I want it's I mean
Knight F2 this game is over but look how
beautiful this move Knight F2 is
you take with the Knight
yes you take with the king I take it I
take on e4 and by the way I'm also
breaking through on a Chief's side right
Knight to F2 ends the game but it's the
only move that actually maintains the
advantage you have to be very careful
will she find it she spent a lot of time
for this move Knight to E5 actually went
from 24 minutes to 17 minutes now this
is the key moment whether she finds
Knight F2 or not let's take a look at
her situation right now her reaction
it's it's it's a big moment for this
game because she's been laboring all
this time to try to break through and
finally she has a golden opportunity to
do so but she needs to find this
movement it's neither too like of course
I mean it was just a um how to say when
you ask someone she doesn't know beg him
that there is a move here right now yes
you told you ask this question like find
the move and of course the first crazy
move which came to my mind I just
offered it without calculating let's be
honest here but let's say when you don't
know this View kind of sometimes don't
even look at this direction right now
the thing is you might actually be
forced because if you go back to E5 then
I say 45 and yeah you're losing the
exchange back so uh by elimination you
must be looking at something crazy right
now also not group taxi C4 at least to
my eyes it's appealing right yes you
look at Rook takes E4 you see maybe
Knight F2 coming after that yes and
Knight takes C4 comes back maybe invade
via the second rank that's an option as
well so you start calculating those
moves
but how long she thinks already
she's been thinking for two minutes
okay and perhaps that's not a good not a
good sign for her but yeah uh yeah let's
wait but that's Anastasia what you were
saying about this uh being alerted
it's so absolutely true in some ways I
think these tactical puzzle books
on the board she found it her coach the
coach proud yes yes that's a good move
that's a great one no it is it's a great
move Knight F2 forking the rook and as
you pointed out Knight takes F2 Rook
takes E3 uh black crashes through King
takes F2 Rook takes E4 to make visual
usually right yeah it's it's really
stunning but that was the point I was
wanting to make that sometimes you know
we train ourselves with these puzzle
books but for the wrong thing because
it's sort of like I give you this puzzle
book and it says 1200 checkmating ideas
yes well now you start looking for the
checkmating ideas but when you're at the
board somebody doesn't tap you on your
shoulder says now now you have the
winning tactic the winning combination
the winning Checkmate you don't know
that I don't know that so I mean you
were stimulated when you say okay find
the winning move
you're looking for the shocking move and
that's why they say that sometimes some
good players they just need this kind of
tickling like that's all you need yes
that's a good move like you know so
cheating in the playing Hall can be as
simple as my waving my hand and say now
yes oh there it is thank you for thank
you for pointing that out that was very
kind of you
um back to Jennifer you because again uh
a moment ago we had this question after
the move Queen C3 there's no question
question that Naji is going to move her
Queen
and to take over the C file Queen C7
Queen C8 equally appealing which move do
you choose she chose C8 okay nobody
could understand why until we come to
the game position and we get right here
and
if White
is going to go in Desperate auto mode
and go Pawn to F5 after Pawn takes F5
Queen H5 trying to you know drum up your
own counter play well the nice the good
news is we've already
pre-defended the pawn on F5 with our
Queen being on C8 being on C7 but we
think the well we know the evaluation is
-2 maybe even worse we think that
Jennifer is in an in deep distress at
this moment I think also maybe that the
reason for this move is to play maybe
sometimes Queen A6
Queen A6 yeah it is a good point yes
maybe to press put pressure on A3 bone
and sometimes maybe try to jump to uh
second rank if your queen moves
somewhere right maybe okay like like
okay well that actually shuts down your
queen A6 I apologize
I'm trying to yeah
yes yes so you cannot put pressure
actually wow okay I mean obviously for
me a dream would be to kind of reroute
my knight maybe to a G5 check where I
could uh in this case I need my queen on
D3 so that I could go Queen G6 check and
get a compensation for my last night so
that was why I was attracted to the move
Queen D3 thinking to myself okay if it's
my turn not necessarily that I'm playing
for F5 but maybe I'm playing for Knight
H3 and maybe Queen H7 ideas she went
Knight D3
okay either way she's trying her best
to activate her night and obviously
Knight C5 would be a dream but Rook C2
is the problem and doesn't that just put
the kibosh on White's position
where can I go for example a quindy one
I don't know yet okay just and then
Queen Lance and she went Queen E3 by the
way I think in in case of both Queen D1
and queen E3 as we saw in the game I'm
going to go Queen C3 okay the idea is
that your queen and Rook are let's say
tethered together
do my best to resist yeah
oh 91 yeah I keep I cover everything
okay uh Queen E3 have I missed something
oh
H4 and by the way after Queenie Queen C3
yeah can I try to do F5 and do something
very similar to what I did previously
just to invade with my queen
yeah anything that kicks up a fuss uh
I'm all in favor uh
yeah so what else instead of maybe
Queen's history maybe three something
like H4 what's the idea I'm the pond
grubber I'll I'll take it okay I mean if
you go Queen to G5 that is another Pawn
with a check
I mean I don't think you can afford this
but I could be wrong I mean how how big
is your how dangerous I want to say is
your play like you can still protect the
fight for sure maybe even yeah like
before
yeah I'm not
quite sure but Knight F4 is annoying to
me
um well okay another thing maybe after
uh it takes at five maybe I can go E6
ooh
she's played Queen C3 we may be heading
into this direction and Jennifer almost
immediately was reaching for F Pawn well
I don't think she has a lot of options
no she doesn't
um
but F5 is the is the money move I mean
to try to immediately and she's done it
too oh F5 to get in her own
um counter checks and maybe equalize uh
per pet yeah Bravo maybe sometimes it
can be really unpleasant from like if
you don't play the Right Moves you can
maybe we'll you can get to the dangerous
position like something what I what
we've seen with this six nights with
five I don't Queen G5 I don't know
what's going on exactly Queen G5 or E6
what uh Christian just prescribed
Christian uh jump in on this one because
I mean the U.S Champion ladies
championship title is on the line it's
critical this one is critical with only
three rounds after this one to go right
I mean this is a make or break situation
and moment for Jenny for you we know
Nazi bike is a problem is not in the
hunt for the championship no but Journey
for you I mean if she wins this one and
she could be winning this one if she
takes on F5 because after E6 she's
winning
show us how yes absolutely so taking on
F5 is already a huge mistake really E6
wins at the game for white because you
go King to by the way you cannot take
back yes and this is the key because
Knight to E5 and I have a rook on a G3
Queen on E3 I'm going into this one C3
I'm going to be a rookout right yeah so
you have to go King to E8 but now I'm
invading right right now I go Queen to
E5 right and how do you defend Bishop to
E4 maybe sure but then I take you start
seeing some checkmates you have to do 57
yes you're not going to survive this one
I can just even uh take on C7 and play
the move Knight to C5 even that end game
I think uh you're slightly worse but
most likely I have ideas of just keeping
the queen on the board with Queen to G8
King to E7 Knight to C5 right now you
can touch this because you're going to
get checkmated right yes that's a check
that's just seven yes so wow dangerous
play for a Nazi by kids right now uh the
white King has been in danger for quite
a while right
attacking this G2 Pawn but right now the
blacking on F7 is getting exposed and
it's not going to be easy to defend this
position I'm telling you I got my uh my
heart it's like really because we went
from you know Jennifer was plus six I
mean she had the game in the bag uh to
the situation she was down to and then
maybe Queen C3 is when a one was played
Queen A1 is that an accuracy no it's
it's the right move that was the right
move it was the right move but still the
position is just simply equal right now
so this position an equal is a funny
yeah yeah I know you're about your
triple zeros you go you know what you
can do with your triple zero equal is a
funny thing yes of course it's not uh
it's not equal it's balanced from I mean
what is the next move after King H2
portal black maybe you have to go I have
to F1
well that is a made on G2 that I'm
staring at correctly and maybe if you go
Knight F4 can I go Rook C1
Knight F4 Rook C1 and I'm staring out at
another so the only way is to try to
create your own Checkmate patterns
otherwise you probably you just lose the
disposition how do we defend after a
queen to F1 is the question
and she's played it and we're expecting
the queen F1 which of course uh does
harmonize nicely but here I can check
yes right so if you take with the bishop
that gives me a Tempo that I need
because I don't have to defend and if
you take with a king
that's bad news so you're probably going
to have to back away right so what if I
take on E6 with the bishop with a bishop
unless you don't you are not threatening
to take on jittu anymore right what do
you do
um can you help someone
Queen to Chief Queen to Chief wow maybe
D5 or six no
I don't know I mean it's just like so I
think this is by the way this is quite
cute yeah if you go Queen F4 okay it
looks like you're getting a favorable
end game right you're a pawn up yes and
you have full control and you're
starting to go D5 you're losing H4 after
I take take H4 H4 yes because
G3 is coming and made on the first round
stuff that is that's this is nice crazy
yes okay so King H2 Queen F1 I I mean I
rushed to play this move but it should
be six maybe five no I
okay hold on I can do
I'm really uh my my brain hurts here
just a sec
let's check this version e f takes C6
official takes and then I proposed this
move D5 here try and talk about this
but we were happy to kick the bishop
away from it but I haven't before by
seven I'm a bone Grabber oh good good
for you yeah but I don't know so I saw
the check and I thought I will try to
run away and do I have anything here
well once again I mean this this
41 in the worst case
there's long moves with screen
it's not the the threat of mate on g2s
not so fearsome you're saying
wow at least the H4 is not losing
because now I can take on G4 right with
my Bishop is not protecting good point
yes
um so you have to do something and if
you move your queen to E2 wow wow I
don't know like I have so many bones by
the way okay yeah guys please what a
tense game yes no it's a fantastic game
it it's ridiculously enthralling
it's amazing game the pendulum swings
with the AIDS
but from a practical perspective it
looks so complex yes if you don't know
the evaluation you might be able to say
yes black is better or white is better
right
I lost this position already three times
for black and it shows actually that
every move can bring you uh no efforts
with no efforts Anastasia I mean you've
lost them yes simply and beautiful or
both sides right yeah and I mean you
know you you you're just so tempted good
you you just want to capture this ball
and you don't want to see the queen
landing on your doorstep and taking
pawns with check we know she's played
the movie all right now it's this is a
big moment once again
every movie is a big moment
I don't remember already take on E6
seems to be the right way yes and then
in fact the only way so if we didn't
afford is bad we you'd explained why so
what is the move here D5 so D5 is
correct D5 is correct yes sir
again where's Chris bird fair play ideas
that you take on D5 now I go Queen F4 ah
okay okay I didn't go so far war check
that's a pretty one and because once
again the bishop has been distracted
from the G4 and even though you didn't
pick up the pawn uh you are at least
forking uh this and I think the troubles
have passed by the way I just wanted to
boldly State the obvious I didn't want
to do it at the time but were we
disrespected by Hans when he came in and
he said you know these low living
podcasters and you know commentators but
he didn't mention any names on every
level
right exactly
I've done it before even right we'll do
it again Eric's house uh that was that
that's a pretty line and that's the
equalizing line let's see guys right
once again she's taken on E6 options of
going King E8 King G8 is even a move in
the position okay let's try to figure
out king E8 King E8 Anastasia we're
gonna lose this like once twice in three
years already
but that's the first time no no no no
well I wanted to ask you is it lost I go
Rook takes G4
right I'm trying to figure it out I'm so
confused okay I messed it up
okay
then I'm gonna go take the bishop right
okay sorry uh what did you do Christian
you got it this time no I'm actually
going to go Bishop A8 instead of Rook C1
um
hero chance of course not I mean
d58 yeah don't ask me what the
difference between
I know the difference because you moved
your Bishop now it's not hanging so now
Rook C1 and you don't have room
but what's the difference between and
Bishop B7 no no no this don't even know
we are not going into this discussion I
am ready for you Anastasia please the
floor is yours
I don't know I don't know either so like
D5 works you want yes so I still have
these three nice pawns maybe I will have
four cones for The Rook who knows Rook
G4 and then here we go d67
this game is completely cool you go D5
Rook C1 Rook G4 what did you say how
many pounds did you already I think
it's I mean it's impressive
form because this bounce double bonds we
don't count them oh my gosh okay that is
just too crazy yes uh by the way uh we
do have this position you also mentioned
King G8
is even a possibility Christianity
is also a possibility it's seven just in
case I just hold on mate on G2 I know
you don't want yes to play it
immediately I just mean there is this
option sometimes even so now you have to
of course you have to go and you're
saying that one day E7 could be like you
could do something like 27. for example
oh my gosh this is wildly complicated
yes right wildly complicated I mean here
we are you know going back and forth
amongst ourselves we've got engines
which we're trying not to use and we're
just like uh putting our minds together
and it's still
um it's a challenge yes it's complicated
it's to position for three results oh
gosh
everything is possible one move you make
and you can kind of lose it immediately
it feels like a position for Five
results
I don't know what what the other results
could leave it I mean this is
yes this is a patient's position for it
so it takes on E6 what for me is
absolutely absolutely fantastic is
Bishop takes E6 D5 Bishop takes D5 Queen
F4 check beautiful move the bishop has
been distracted away from the Pawn on G4
making
nullifying Black's ability to play H4
and white is out of trouble Harm's Way
um big moment here uh can
well what uh Christian helpers out
Bishop takes E6 which we know
if if Naji was in such a mood that said
I have to play for a win right a losses
is is is this famous for me um what
would be the most
problems
even though King 38 is very tempting as
well right so King to G8 and now um it
does seem like we're probably going to
have to enter a position such as Knight
to F4 okay that defends that defends G2
yes yeah
um and uh now Eric to C1
not moving the bishop but Rook to see
one move to C1 now and then we were most
likely going to see a queen take C1
Queen takes C1 Knight takes D5 ah okay
also this option is possible so it's
better to give up a queen than an
exchange well let's try to understand
why so okay if you go to G
yes this position yeah okay and this
would be I go Queen to C4 yes take some
pot but yeah not 100 sure who's better
in the position two
uh well if you win on my pawns I I can
tell you who's going to be better right
right right right then yes but that's
probably why you don't even want to go
E7 in that position it remains
there you go she's got it you have to
wow Brave to play this movie you know
agree agree except in the fact that this
phone and you can see that white is not
losing immediately like you have Knight
F4 move and so you have to be really
Brave to find King Jade wow truly yes
absolutely I mean I I tell you there it
was inspiring yesterday Alice Lee seeing
her play for a win against a-time U.S
women's champion Arena crash and
refusing Time After Time repetitions and
uh well we're seeing incredible uh play
once again Knight F4 Rook C7
is the only move now Knight F4 is they
have to be very very careful with white
as well Knight F4 is the only move
Knight to four after King g80s and if
you go Rook C1 again another I'd rather
give up my exchange than my queen and
what if I go Rook to E1
after Rook takes G4 yeah yes you don't
take it we need to eat one one and then
what
okay okay hold on I oh you're
threatening check and to take my queen
with Jack so I was thinking okay I have
time to go E7 no I do not Queen H1 and
Rook takes E3 that's important yes so
okay now I
where can I go with my queen
um
okay let me just throw out that's a
problem because I go Queen G1 rookie
three yes
I pick everything we check
that is beautiful beautiful so I I have
no place to put my queen no I have to
say Okay seven okay yes we're ready to
give this rook in any case and then what
check and then 95. then what which one
is a threat no no no no I'm not no I'm
not I'm
oh not again she's he's got the same
idea
oh shoot I snake uh to your king you
sure did oh shoot maybe you have to play
E7 for example yes C7 in order to try to
give as many checks as possible before
you resign
well thank you for the good news
wait a minute wait a minute I think I I
blundered into a discovery check this
out if you take my Pawn that's a check
might do five okay it gives some chances
then and then I have a chance to move my
queen and gosh knows what's going on I'm
looking at Jennifer shaking and I'm
shaking with her I understand why she's
a nervous uh a ball of nerves at the
moment both of them are I guarantee you
that both of them are Nazi is definitely
wearing it better
no shaking very professional but
sometimes even though the table is
moving you know it's moments like one of
them who who had the he I mean mean
Bobby Fischer had the leg shake he had
that too but I'm thinking there was a a
player in my practice I don't believe it
was at U.S championships where the legs
were shaking and the table was shaking
and pretty soon I'm shaking
like I'm wondering what's going on and
then we speak about meditation yes so
immediately you come to this mode of
meditation and everybody is like
different deep deep breaths deep deep
breaths yeah
um what a position sorry the other games
were kind of losing track uh yes tell us
what's going on in begum's game so Talia
is definitely going to win her game
right he kind of knew that for a while
against Megan yeah that end game it's
you cannot see she was picking up the
pawn on B6 which and she did nothing
actually improved for white D5 D4 D3 is
coming yes there's no stabbing poor
Megan who just lost two games in a row
and and she also losing her did she lose
two games yes yes
she was in the lead
she got leapfrogged by Jennifer You by
losing yesterday wow she lost again and
she's going to be stuck at six for the
last two rounds uh no wait sorry she
lost to beg him she lost to beg him I
think yesterday with begging me yeah
yeah baking was actually remember
telling that she was a bit nervous
is now in a basic rook and pawn ending
that's a draw known draw The Rook just
comes to the sixth rank weights weights
waits for you to play F six so that you
can go King G6 and only when the pawn is
on F6 do I go to the on the bottom of
the board and harass from behind so
that's Sophie has got a draw if she
defends it accurately what happened to
ashrita
after this great move Knight F2 we
thought it was winning for begin and is
it was it it was yeah yeah and it still
is but there's still a technical task
ahead of bagim okay and undoubtedly so
and ashrita is is fighting very well she
created this past one which at least
looks dangerous yeah menacing and Knight
to F7 picked it up Knight to D6 went
back to F7 makes a lot of sense right
it's just that the position is so short
of material but again trying to exchange
everything right that's the question yes
yes because the question it's almost
like this Pawn is a goner I mean King
can come this Pawn is going to be very
hard to defend as well like I couldn't
start with this but also I'm thinking I
should
the the one that may hurt now I go 95
right and that defends and before and C4
pawns and also the C4 party you're right
and it's still not clear I mean you can
take on C5 even at that point and what
is this is is this super lost it's not
clear yes Knight B5 by the way is on the
board
your move 95 yes
well I don't want to take credit for bad
positions just a second
i-2e5 has been played by also yes
of course you won't you try by the way
we also had one remaining game in the
open and that was Jeffrey Zhang did he
draw that we were thinking Sam Shanklin
yes a long while ago so that completes
C5 girls are playing right now
hey hard fighting hard fight now you
take C5 so she's got a shritha pardon me
she's got Knight E6 check and Knight
takes f4 on her agenda I'm expecting F3
right right
that's a very strong move and the
question is where do you put your king
now exactly well if I put my king on G3
I'm only inviting Rook G7 precisely yes
and if I put my king on F2 well I take
on H3 and then Knight G4 and this Pawn
is uh is running yes
so F3 is the money move why do you play
after F3 do you go to H2
but then do you stop the pawn is the
question I go F2 right
F2 King she's playing yeah
I move to F7 could I play instead of
this here for King G3 yes F2 and then F2
yes yes
and now Rook H2 pardon me Rook H2 and
Rook H1 are your winning yeah this is
winning yeah yeah it's a win and F3 is
on the board wow
okay for begum by the way
a lot of players have been on a very
strange roller coaster ride and begum is
certainly one of them I mean she's had
her moments in the Sun but equally you
know she's had some real ah difficult
down moments yes and she's doing really
well I like how she she copes with the
pressure she said okay yes I lost the
game so I'm ready to fight the next day
it's okay life continues exactly great
example how you deal with you when you
lose your game because we had that
question uh do they uh from our audience
was like how do you deal with these
losses how do you mentally approach the
next games and King F2 on the board
and she's uh I don't know
yes it's the hover why not
and again
how I mean it's nice that uh
these nights
are over there but over there means that
this Pawn Knight G4 check and F2 it's
going to promote now you probably have
to go back right to E4 try to stop that
pawn right somehow and Nike for check
yes or you go to G1
Knight to q1 for me
King the G1 King to G1 yeah G3 check
okay
pardon me F2 checks
Rook to G3 check and that's over and
then once you go to F1 you step into
that pin and you're right that's over
whoo
wait is it over though what is it over I
go King G2 after F3 oh no oh no just
when I'm expecting uh a hearty hand
class
that was a mouse slip apologies
it still probably is winning after okay
to an A6 right I'll play A6
this is nice
for yassers
[Music]
nice
and although we haven't mentioned her
game that much we were expecting Anna
and what what just happened this one
Anna went into Bishops of opposite color
position but somehow she lost her whole
Queen side got eviscerated
what could Alice be no Alice could not
be with no Alex might be winning guys no
really yes yeah like what do you need to
play now for example H3 Bishop before
why not why not and then the king runs
it's the right color Bishop right so I I
run yeah I don't think I think you're
just one Temple away because you're
going to lose the G2 yes you have no
time to protect the spawn yes well then
you will have two various a Wi-Fi
let's see G3 yeah
it's still not over C3 King C4
being there and if I go King B3 you go
King D2 yes and I just keep you out of
C2 and B1 where's the win yeah I think
you you rushed A3 a moment ago perhaps
so here after the move Bishop f8 maybe
you start with the king move wow that's
actually a very important point so that
uh you don't lose the Stampy and now it
just came the street thank you well I'm
not a 100 sure because here
if you go here I go here so I'm
threatening I'm threatening both yeah
yeah King C1 but Kim
thank you yes it clears the cobwebs
I go King here you can do one
and the idea is Bishop C1 yeah so you're
right
and we don't have time
tricky endings yes so my dream is this
Anna's dream will be to play King C1 and
Bishop E5
is time a factor Anastasia that's a good
question let's see the time
I don't see from here because normally
Anna is the one who's always in time
trouble always relying upon
uh her increments
I can't she got tricked uh beg him that
is really yeah begum got tricked that
game seems to have gotten directly to
tell for me
sorry you said begum has also slipped no
maybe not so much but I think she had a
much better opportunity there King G3
you know we're like E3 we're looking at
A6 weren't we yes yes
A6 is only just don't follow our great
analysis no 97 Rook C2 that's easy but
Knight A7 so Rook F7
correct so yeah I mean she designs
that's a resignation okay
you know every coach he's so nervous
that he starts to see some ghosts even
okay compositions after King GM I'm
jumping quickly to the game of Jennifer
and Nazi after King G8 this uh this
incredible move by Naji not going for
that Bishop takes E6 Knight F4 Rook C1
straight into that variation right she
took on C1 and took the bishop and we're
expecting Queen C4 yes four minutes for
uh Jennifer you eight minutes for Naji
unbelievable how well they play but by
the way that oh you imagine you play all
this game already for years foreign
you can easily uh not take into
consideration because you see Rook to C3
right yeah and you start to get scared
C8 E7 and yes who's winning now you
start to get scared right yes let's
start to find
I mean you've got you you start looking
at who's playing you know how how do I
bail out with uh create as a threat
right and you probably have to take on
D4 first not on D5 uh pardon me uh just
a moment ago here take on D4 first and
not ADI wow how counter-intuitive is
that not to take a piece but to take uh
upon but now you start to understand why
we're doing this
now we make a draw well okay I don't
know who feels a greater sense of relief
after after all of these this uh
excitement it's it's a it's been a wild
game and it's been a completely true now
if you ask me yes sir who deserves this
kind of price a brilliant surprise this
game for sure both of them played really
really interesting game remarkable game
yeah
and again I I said it coming into the
start of the show you know you look for
inspiration and you see these uh well I
want to say Gladiators uh we're your
real fears Warriors and what Alice Lee
did last yesterday was remarkable I I
remember such a moment when Magnus
Carlson played in the original the very
first sinful cup he's a half a point
ahead of Lavon going into last game if
he makes a draw Magnus wins 100 000 the
inaugural event of the sink fill cup
Lavon offers Magnus a draw
Magnus says let's play
unbelievable refuses a draw that
guarantees him first yes and Magnus goes
on to win the game Maurice and I were
just electrified we just like taser
because all our careers we're taught you
know yes
and you're first yes no no no same
happened in 2013 World Championship
match against Talent if you remember
lucky already he needed just half a poet
in order to win the match he got this
really great position he could make a
draw any moment but he was fighting
until the end trying to win also this
game and at the end it was a draw
imagine what we just got your world
championship title and he was upset that
he didn't need to win the game finish it
in the style he had hoped Queen G5
finals
wow what a move by uh Queen G
is that is that is that good I mean
you've got a guest and we've got a crazy
game going on but over to you Christian
we do and we'll uh be sure by the we are
with Group after an important Victory
against ashwita srita has been a very
difficult uh player to gauge because she
was winning a lot of games she was then
losing a lot of which ashwita did you
expect to get today I wasn't sure that's
why I was a little bit worried because
sometimes she comes to the round and
crushes everyone like she I checked for
games she played so like strong I was
like I don't know which one I'm gonna
get but it was like in between right she
didn't collapse anywhere definitely a
streaky player Now take us through uh
the critical moments and specifically
after the opening because I have a
feeling I messed that up a little bit
like G5 F5 it was just too ambitious
after exchange during the Bishops we
don't have anything I was just hoping
that she's gonna exchange the queen
things like that because I saw that I
have E4 so you saw this from afar this
yeah yeah before I played like Queen D7
I saw that idea that Bishop is hanging
all the time so I just hope for this but
even after that I don't have like
I don't have much but still it's it's
not as easy yeah exactly easy but I'm I
need to give my phone back but my
position is great so I thought I'm gonna
press here and actually at this point
you had this uh electrifying move okay
that's why I didn't take uh didn't you
sell it immediately Knight to F4 did you
spot this idea oh Knight to F4
knightware for yes which wins the game
is it yes because you take take and now
you put the king anywhere no
yes but I I thought about The Rook
Giselle and I was like wait a second I
should be able to take it but like for
some reason I forgot night F4 back and
then
you uh ladies were just like shuffling
the pieces I saw the idea of his uh
Knight p392 but I wanted to make it to
the uh like 40 moves so I will get
Farthing hours that after that I thought
I'm gonna like go think about it I just
knew that if I put my king on G6 then
she has always whenever I get this
position Canon G6
share the move
or Knight G4 and after Knight E5 idea no
no not here not in this place at some
point my king was on G6 if I would play
a knight B3 Rook D3 90 bd2 uh Rook D1
and Knight E4 when night her night was
night on G5 and then there's some 95
ideas Knight E5 is a check so I couldn't
uh like go to that line with my king on
G6 and I couldn't go with my King on
East G7 because so he tried to hide the
King on f8 for example yeah if I got can
you go yes a little bit forward
yeah move forward here no instead of
Knight C3
if
if I had my king on jisan for example
she could play Knight F5 check that's
why I was just shuffling and trying to
figure out where to put the king and
basically I just waited for 14 minutes
right and did you see this move Knight
to F2 from afar yeah sure so you were
playing it's beautiful I was like that's
very nice very nice I saw that she
played Knight C3 I thought oh it's
losing then I spotted a free idea but
after F3 I saw Knight F2 which is so
beautiful I'm like I'm gonna go and
after that you convert it nicely
congratulations uh beg him a big victory
for you guys any questions not at all
but just to let you know begum your
coach was very proud of you he was
taking a great deal of credit on your
success
I did not say
[Laughter]
exactly as you should uh crazy things
are happening Anna zatonski uh to
understand a bishop and a pawn down but
a dead draw yeah when I first realized
that this was a draw by the way I just
it shocked me that you could be a bishop
and a pawn up yes and can't win the game
yes and uh that will be a draw uh but
this game between Jennifer you and um
has just been a drama in five parts I
mean it's it's crazy but after this move
Rook C3 with the with the threatening uh
E6 check it is time yes just to to end
time to end this game yeah this
incredible game with a Perpetual again
the threat of E6 check
what if black tried to win still and the
game as we've just seen is over a young
13 year old Alice
she was completely winning in this end
game okay oh no at this point she played
this move King to E4 which I know the
king to get close to the pawn okay
and G5 and G5 precisely how do you get
your Bishop precisely
yeah your Bishop is overloaded the same
ideas tried the linear Domingos
yesterday right so if you go here now I
go G5 and how do you get you can't get
to H2 you're not in time wow you're
simply not in time to touch this Pawn
this promotion square and the H2 Square
wow a huge missed opportunity for Alice
how much time did she have at this point
so I'm kind of curious okay 15 minutes
she should have
lack of experience yes and she's only 13
years of age she will learn with time
and that could have been huge again for
our standings
and uh as expected this game between
Jennifer and Naji yes please H4 just to
um I like this game so much just to make
sure that it's completely we're playing
with fire
uh well let's start yes I cannot play in
anywhere with the king so Queen takes
only choice and Rook let's say goes
Queen chat I still have drawn I'm not I
don't know
uh because there's some kind of a mutual
your queen is mutual respect
position
right I mean I don't know six I cannot
play because Knight C7 and yeah oh my
God look at this game maybe you would
start to think why didn't I make my
Perpetual check but it's nice of you to
ask out of curiosity absolutely
absolutely yeah well I think we're going
to see a repetition in this one it
doesn't seem like she's going to try for
anything
and Talia has won her uh third straight
game if I'm not mistaken yes yes it puts
her half a point behind Jennifer I think
one full point behind you no because
Jennifer makes a draw and she has seven
and Thalia will have six I mean she has
already six so it means one point what a
game oh that's right because Natalia had
the wind to catch up to make it I
apologize he doesn't jump past Megan yes
okay so she is one point behind and
Jennifer right I think these ladies are
stopping okay they've made the draw
they're they're getting confirmed and
then now they're asking each other what
was going on
like nobody knows nobody knows uh wasn't
I better
um
or 25. did I miss a win yes uh oh Chris
is saying by the way I think that's
right Frank is is giving them a heart or
is that yes he's trying to he's telling
them repeat it one more time or write it
one more time or something right
uh okay you have to be an Orbiter man
nobody likes you the the the players
don't like you exactly when you tell
them to like uh yeah sure make sure
you're following the protocol they don't
want to listen to you right now I mean
right it's crazy boldly stating the
obvious we had those days where white
could only win games only white was
winning games then we had those games it
was like a Black Tuesday or something
only black could win today
today what only draws one with the black
yes okay Italian yes one with the black
pieces
um I remember a couple of drawers
no wins with the white pieces it's it's
crazy right yes I mean we're either on
or
um it depends on what's going on what
games are remaining yes
which I think that would be a draw very
soon okay
but Rue Yang is a pawn up she was an
exchange up for most of the game Sabine
has been fighting to hold the position
uh my first impression is that black
should be winning
my first impression because somehow this
Pawn
the past Pawn is actually very firmly
blockaded and I've got two connected
past pawns and I might be able to you
know utilize them by taking over the
fourth rankings and things like this so
my first impression is Sabina as as hard
fighting and she's she's accomplished
she hasn't gotten there and this would
yet be another win with the black Pieces
by the way let's see what tatv and
Sophie
well wait a minute Sophie
Sophie didn't hold on what the heck is
going on nothing nothing nothing
whatever you do is I mean she should
have kept the Rook on the sixth right
like but then she played rookie six so
that kind of forces you to get away from
this okay so the whole point is like in
this exact position like a losing move
would be a move like this because then I
I kicked the king away from the
promotion square with check and check so
what you have to do is black in this
position pardon me
is whenever you you have to drop back
with the Rook so you could go Rook check
whether you go King F6 Rook F7 check or
if you go King G6 Rook G7 check and
that's the drawing mechanism but I think
Sophie's made it a little bit more
difficult than was her intention yes it
looks like wow wow Anastasia I forgot to
say this round 10 if the round before
the free day yes and I think that also
how do you say gives the players a
permission
when it's the round before the free day
I have felt that that I could go all out
like I just pour all the energy that I
could into the game I didn't try to Pace
myself anymore and then recharge on the
free day and I think the kind of
fighting games we had today are
indicative that the players are well
aware there is another possibility like
some people they kind of already start
dreaming about these three days right
but like LaVon and Wesley just like
let's get out everyone just to have this
free day finally right you want to sell
that too so free they maybe sometimes oh
yeah it depends on your situation in the
tournament but it turned out that the
open section they finished their games a
long time ago and the ladies are still
alive yes exactly so I think it's two
different approaches and it was shown
today in the boss events yes exactly
exactly and I think we're getting ready
for another guest in studio as we review
our results thus far only two games
remaining in this round 10. and we have
three draws between Jennifer you with
crazy Kevin lazy but it's by kids Arena
crash made a draw with Rochelle Anna
zatoski who survived against Ellis Lee
and the term that survived is right yes
and then we have two decisive games
Talia one against Megan Lee and also beg
him who won against Africa and I think
we have Talia or no not yet we don't
have not yet I guess but we're expecting
it and the drama
the drama of uh the realm this game of
Jennifer you and I feel like I could
write a novel about that book and what's
what's the results in the open section
all the games are finished yes all the
games are over and we have the Statics
Fabiano is on the first place as before
I think actually everything remained
more or less the same so mentioned that
hands demon kind of moved up a little
bit
behind him and then we have a really big
group of people linear Domingo's Jeffrey
Jones Sam Shanklin dairus Sam Sabian and
a Wonderland was five and a half points
and then we see
Wesley saw together with Alex Slenderman
and Hans Neiman or whisk
and al-shan is suffering in this event
so far truly truly a lot of suffering
going on from elshon at this moment
the same time this last three rounds and
everything can happen still yes and the
moment if for example Fabiano will not
speed up and we'll sleep a little bit
then the others will have chance to
catch him and this is it's great about
this event that still everybody kind of
keeps keeps chances to fight for three
first positions exactly for me it was
extraordinary to see the very young 15
year old Christopher Yu playing
such a mature game as he has he kept
control over his much wanted opponent
Fabiano Fabiano was really under duress
maybe for the first
well a time in this U.S Championship
that Bobby uh was the one that wasn't
pressing that he was the one
suffering and he did make a draw but it
wasn't it wasn't comfy yes but
he was trying to defend actually
actively right he was not just standing
and waiting for his opponent he found
all deceptive moves exchange all the
pawns on the king side to make sure that
I mean follow the rules right how do you
make a draw in this type of situations
uh just looking at this game between
Tata and Sophie for a moment there is a
one wrong mechanism that you should
really really be aware of and that is
after the move King F7 I want to go Rook
here so I could go Rook check and skewer
there is this uh one that you should
know after check your king goes back
King here and it would appear that
you're stuck because like you know like
any Rook moves like Rook down allows F7
and if you allow me to go
excuse me and I'll mate you but you do
have
that's your saving Saving Grace uh Rook
G7 check so we do expect to draw here
but uh we said that for some time
Christian over to you uh it tell us your
thoughts of this a tumultuous uh round
hen yeah it's uh been a crazy round and
a lot of changes feel like they're
Brewing at the top as we enter the
second rest day and especially in the
ladies section I have to say Jennifer
you she was completely lost today I mean
I think it was minus four minus five but
the position was just so ugly you
couldn't develop any of your pieces and
she managed to turn it around right she
turned it around she was winning after
that she gave the advantage away just a
completely crazy round but you see Talia
catching up she's on six uh out of on
ten right now we see him as well getting
close behind only one Point behind the
leaders this one is not in the books yet
and the open section of course Fabiano
caruana still maintaining the lead but
Ray Robson also is still very closely
behind he's going to come down to the
last three rounds and most likely is
going to come down to the championship
round the last final round
wow oh exciting exciting you have uh the
game between Sabina and Rue Yang and
behind you and uh I I was just wondering
did she didn't try to go for a Checkmate
or anything like that she said if I
trade Queens I'm gonna have two
connected pass pawns and I've got this
Pawn Under Wraps like I've got it
blockaded and this Rook on F2 will will
be playing a completely defensive role
and I should win the game and I think
that that's what's going to happen we're
going to see yet another uh win for
black yes we're expecting a draw in the
other remaining game between tatv and
um Sophie and I have to say
um once again great broadcast all good
things must end we have to call it the
day yes we have a rest day tomorrow
don't join us tomorrow but be sure to
join us Monday Tuesday and Wednesday as
we bring you the finish uh concluding
three rounds of these U.S championships
good night everyone good night
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited